Turn this up a little bit.
Just the daycare.
We're up,
we're live.
We're taking,
goddammit.
You good Tom Rhodes,
everything groovy over there.
Indeed sir.
This episode is brought to you by tea.
There's no ting.
I don't need a thing.
Audible.
Yes.
Audible episode is brought to you by
audible.com if you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you will get free 30 days use of
audible.com and a a free audio book.
audible.com is one of the
best resources online.
I would say like the best as far
as audio content for commuting,
for going to the gym for,
you know,
whatever you have to do.
Are you sitting there?
It's normally just wasted time.
You can have a good time with
an audio book and you know,
it's a bad ass audio book when you park
your car and you're sitting in there
cause you don't want it to end.
And that's the difference between a
regular commute and a commute when you're
listening to something cool.
Um,
in some people say like,
well that's what we use your podcast for.
Well thank you.
I'm glad if that's the case.
Thank you very much.
I'm glad you enjoy it,
but sometimes you probably don't want
to listen to me anymore and I feel the
same way.
I don't want to listen to me anymore.
I don't listen to this fucking podcast.
Sometimes you gotta mix it up.
You want some Joe Rogan some Steinbeck.
Mixing it up is important
in this fucking life.
Don't mix me up.
It's time back though.
I just,
I just don't feel it's a fair comparison.
It's not the same heart.
Um,
I bet Steinbeck.
We have a boring fucking podcast.
How about that?
I fucking said it,
Tom Ross.
I don't give a fuck dude.
I'm gangster when I'm
talking about dead dudes.
Uh,
uh,
but anyway,
if you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you get a free audio book is hundreds
of thousands of titles there.
You can also get podcasts,
including the brilliant Dan
Carlin hardcore history.
Just like one of my favorite
podcasts of all time.
I've learned more about history from
Dan Carlin than I ever did in my three
years of barely paying attention college.
And all the time that
I was in high school,
this one dude and his crazy fucking
podcast and you can get all of his back
order,
uh,
his episodes,
they're brilliant.
They're like,
they're,
they're like,
it's not just like a podcast.
It's like a show,
like he puts on a historical show.
It's so dramatic.
It's fucking fantastic.
I can't,
I literally can't recommend it enough.
Um,
but that's also available on audible.com
or also brought to you by hover.
Hover is the same company or it's rather
is owned by the same people that own
ting.
And a hover is a really easy intuitive
website to purchase web domains and they
may get super easy.
I've purchased domains
from them personally.
Um,
they,
they have free things that
other people make you pay for.
Like who is domain name privacy,
uh,
which is like,
it's a real pain in the ass if you,
uh,
if you're a freak and you get some weird
shit out there online and you know,
people know about it.
It was just something back in the day,
there was a time Tom Rhodes where if you
had party in your mouth.com and you put
that up online,
people would go after you
Dick Party in your mouth.
It's just,
I'm just saying if that was your thing,
somebody just snatching up
that donate domain right now.
We already did it.
We already have.
If you go to hover.com forward slash
Rogan you get 10% off your domain name
registrations.
Again,
it's super intuitive,
very easy.
I am not tech savvy by any
stretch of the imagination,
so if I can go there and
do it without a hitch,
you can too.
Go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash
rogue and get 10% off your domain name
registrations on.
We also have already shift fears,
legs.com uh,
yes,
that's right.
There's a bunch of a different silly
sites that Brian has registered while the
show's been going on,
including dig party in your mouth.com.
Yeah.
And uh,
what was the other one?
We haven't really gay one that works
like Tom Sports or something like,
I don't even remember what
age it just squirt burt.com.
It just took you to death squad
to get a desk water squirt.
Bert has a special surprise
that I can't show on,
uh,
on the,
on the Ustream.
They'll kick us off.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com if you've heard about on it
before you probably
heard about supplements.
Uh,
but there's other things besides
like protein things we sell,
including fitness equipment,
all like the,
in my opinion,
the best stuff for developing functional
strength and staying fit and just
making sure that,
you know,
just put in the work and make
sure that your body functions.
It's not saying you have to be a
bodybuilder or a super athlete,
but I swear to you,
have you just put in some work,
couple of days a week
to three days a week,
just exert yourself and you don't
necessarily have to have a trainer.
You can do it yourself.
Um,
I think you should learn PR good form
whenever you lifting weights or doing
anything with kettle bells
or anything where it's like,
you know,
you could hurt yourself,
but it was as long as you learn
good form and use discipline,
you could just follow DVDs.
We have two available on
at.com from Keith Webber,
these extreme kettlebell
cardio workout DVDs.
You don't need fucking anything else then
those DVDs for the rest of your life,
they will crush you.
Those,
those DVDs are amazing and you can do
them with like a single 35 pound kettle
bell,
including the primate bells that we
saw it on it that looked like angry
chimpanzees.
They're fucking bad ass.
Um,
besides that,
there's protein supplements,
cognitive enhancing supplements,
and during supplements,
all kinds of cool shit.
You probably heard this all
before me talking about it,
but there's nothing I can do.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I must continue talking about it in
the same boring manner as before.
However,
we're almost there.
I see the light at the end of the tunnel.
Go buy some buffalo jerky
son gets a freak on,
get some hemp force protein powder.
And if you use a code name Brogue and
you save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
that's it.
God dammit.
I think Brian and he cakes coming up.
Jeff squad Friday ice house.
That's what Friday ice house.
You went through it.
Yeah.
You meet Joey Diaz.
Tom Rhodes is Italian town Friday.
Yeah.
Love to do the show.
This is how we roll.
Ladies and gentlemen put
together shows on the air.
So that's it.
Friday night,
um,
uh,
and a death squad.
Dot TV is Brian's website.
If you want to get any of those
cool teachers that you see,
this kitty cat tee shirts,
he has all those up for sale on death
squad.tv including tour dates and all that
shit.
All free for all.
Like basically all the dudes we hang
out with her was Tony Hinchcliffe for
Thompson girl.
Like anything that comes up,
we have it there.
All right.
It to the music.
Fine.
All right,
well good.
Whoa
new shit.
Powerful.
Yo,
there we go.
Power for world travel.
Tom Rhodes,
you're the fucking man,
dude,
you are.
You are in my opinion,
if you want to like talk about like the,
even if you had to like a romantic
poetic version of the life of the standup
comedian,
then you'd be like an intelligent world
traveler who literally literally lives
out of a suitcase.
Man.
He's just happy going from city to city,
just making people laugh.
But,
but smart and well read,
you know,
you're like a,
you're very prolific dude.
You're like the re like no one
could criticize your road game.
This is not nothing they can say like,
no.
He's like,
Oh man,
I did 300 data sets here.
Oh,
it was funny.
Tom Rhodes is 365.
Okay.
And they were all in another country.
You fucking out there dude.
Uh,
you know,
I'm living the life I dreamed of man.
And I just,
I just fell in love with
a new country I was in.
Well,
I and I,
I should start out saying death squad,
Joe Rogan listeners,
man.
I was in London in January.
Loads of people came to
my show in Australia,
New Zealand.
I always meet cool people,
uh,
you know,
heard me on,
on your show.
And uh,
I was just in New Zealand for a month
and I had the greatest trip of my life.
I did the,
the Auckland,
the New Zealand comedy festival
in Auckland for two weeks.
And then I did this like best of the
fest tour that went all over the country
and I'd never been in New Zealand before.
Wasn't alive.
It's epic.
It's,
it's a habit.
Like I went down,
I went to Hobbiton.
It's there,
there's a town there called
Hamilton and everybody,
all the comedians made fun of Hamilton.
Hamilton was,
is like the shit hole.
It's the Cleveland or whatever.
I actually loved it.
I had some of the best meals,
the food in all the restaurants in New
Zealand where it's really expensive but
very good.
Um,
I had great meals.
There's a street in Hamilton called
Victoria Street and there's a,
it is a little tiny park and
there's a statute of riff raff.
Remember Rocky Horror Picture show?
Let's do the time warp again.
That Guy Richard O'Brien
that played riff Raff,
he wrote that song.
It says a statue of him,
like this gay dude with pumps and like
a space suit and a space gun in his hand
and it's very appropriate that
all the people who do drugs,
it's like this drug park and the people
are slipping in a real street urgent
drug,
addicts slipping in and out of the place.
But that was brilliant that they had
this touch at the entrance of the park or
people that use drugs.
So,
uh,
the,
the tour manager,
I told her they were,
cause you know,
New Zealand is the land of extreme sports.
I wouldn't jump off this fucking chair.
And I said the only thing I want to do
while I'm in New Zealand is as go to the
hobbit house.
So she contacted the dude
that ran the place and uh,
got him tickets cause all those toward
all those festival shows were sold out.
And this,
we got a private tour of,
of Hobbiton.
It's still there.
What does it look like?
Does it look,
it's up on the hill.
It's like I'm one that it's just perfect.
There was a,
uh,
when Peter Jackson was
looking around New Zealand,
he had to be the finest big tree.
Uh,
it's the party tree of,
of Hobbiton.
And so it's this perfect
spot that the guy found.
So it was a real tree that
was there and not still there,
just massive,
beautiful tree.
And there's these hills all around it.
And they built the little hobbit
houses into the side of the,
the thing.
And it did people guard
them like how they keep,
you know,
they do tours.
It's like 70 bucks.
You go on a tour.
But we got a private tour from
the dude that runs a place.
Oh Wow.
And so normally you on the tour,
you can't like go up
to the doors and stuff.
You've got to stay behind
the little tiny fences.
But this dude let us,
we stick our heads out of the doors
and taking pictures and it was raining.
There wasn't very many people there,
but um,
it was,
it was incredible.
And then there's a little tavern at the,
what are the insides of those things?
Looks like nothing.
Cause they had the sets
built in Wellington,
so they just would film people going in,
in and out.
Right.
That was a stupid,
but there's the fence that didn't fit
that bill bell Baggins jumps over the
fence at the beginning.
I'm going on a great adventure
and the dude let me jump over it.
That's fucking awesome.
Wow.
Yeah.
I've never been in New Zealand,
but it looks insane.
It looked so beautiful.
It looks like incredible.
Like the mountains.
Then the north island year,
which they say is the lesser spectacular.
Uh,
I thought it looked like California,
like northern California.
And then the South Island is like,
that's where all the majestic
lord of the rings shots are.
And that's really stunning down there.
Wow.
And that,
why do you say that?
They're like the kings of,
of uh,
extreme sports.
Like what they invented,
bungee jumping and yeah,
that was invented in New Zealand and uh,
all these like crazy.
They're,
that they're all into this crazy,
you know,
anything extreme.
Why,
why is that your thing?
There's this warrior people,
so it goes back to the
Maoris and their manliness.
And that's the key,
the cool thing of,
of New Zealand too.
They get the,
that manly now everything.
I saw a dude,
very tall,
handsome Mallory Guy,
about 25 walking in the street in Oakland
and he had that tattoo on his face.
Oh.
And there was a couple Maori,
um,
comedians and people that worked at the
club where I was playing in Oakland and
they,
I was out,
I was asking him about it.
I should point out that you're
covering your mouth like a,
like a gas mask again,
like a gas mask over the,
exactly.
Precisely.
Wow.
And I asked about it and they were like,
oh yeah,
that dude's very important in his tribe.
He's like,
uh,
you know,
but he was like a young,
young Gish dude.
He's very important.
So he tattoos his mouth.
I,
you know what,
that's an ancient,
ancient tradition.
Ancient.
Yeah.
I saw a woman with facial tattoos,
Maori women,
little tiny things,
which must be badges of honor somehow.
Ooh,
that's,
so that's a crazy culture that
their ticket to the next level.
They're like,
well,
how about we all tend to our face.
Right.
How about that?
Yeah.
I wanted to find out if,
you know how they felt about
the Mike Tyson copying it.
Like if he's like,
they think he's a punk,
you know,
this is a bodybuilder did it too.
I've been asked him everything.
He had the very Mike
Tyson like gigantic dude.
He's got it on his phone and do the dance.
If you're,
if you're going to get the facial tattoo,
you know,
like the,
the Haka.
Yeah.
Isn't that cool?
They danced before their
opponent and rented them.
Yeah.
My friend Steph and uh,
turned me onto that.
He sent it to me the first
time he sent it to me.
It was like a,
it's a beginning of a
rugby match and these,
uh,
the all black,
oh my God,
it's so intense.
It's like the manliest shit that humans
have ever done other than like fight
with swords.
The manliest Shit you
could do is that dance?
Yeah.
Have you seen that?
Brion pull it up.
Pull it up.
Thought Haka Dance.
Yeah.
Let me see if I could find
like a good version of it.
Because a,
there's a black and white,
I think it's an Adidas ad for
like Adidas rugby equipment.
Yeah.
It's just says the Haka Award Dance Rugby.
It's the first one.
If it just,
I love take care.
And you know,
the Maoris,
uh,
you know,
they were never like colonized.
They like constantly fought the
British when the British came.
Like I read the history of Australia,
there's a great book by
Robert Hughes called uh,
the fatal shore and it's all about the
epic founding of Australia who these guys
are doing it.
Yeah.
Was there a beginning?
Yeah,
we missed the EMS,
the dance that would,
they just showed a loans.
Oh No.
Oh,
there you go.
the dance keeps going.
Yeah.
It's,
yeah,
something terrifying
about that kind of energy.
Yeah.
So imagine,
you know,
like the aboriginals in Australia,
when I was going to say from that book,
they were very friendly when the British
and the convicts came and they're like,
you know,
rushed out to the boats and
bringing them fruit and stuff.
The Maoris did nothing but
attack these motherfuckers.
Imagine you're coming from England and
you get off and these native people are
doing this dance to you and they're like,
we're bashing their heads with rocks
and just hiding in caves and guerrilla
warfare to the end.
I mean,
imagine you're like some white Dorky dude
from England and you're a ship arrives
in New Zealand.
He's motherfuckers come out of the cave
and do that grunt dancing to get back on
the motherfucking boat.
Could you imagine if that's your fuck up?
Cause that's what it was back then.
I mean when they were
exploring new countries,
there was a lot of,
it was just like,
you're going to pull into this
harbor and let's see what's up.
Right?
Yeah.
But I ain't never seen a white guy before.
You never seen one of them before.
Captain Cook,
the guy he did was his
greatest English explorer,
I think.
You know,
he found,
uh,
Australia and the Cook Islands,
they,
they killed him in Hawaii.
The natives there.
Fuck candidate.
But he,
you know,
he had a good career leading up here.
Well,
he just,
he was like,
you know,
it's taught luck.
You never know what you're
going to get on certain islands.
You know,
some bring you fruit,
some one,
a bachelor you have
with the fucking right.
Some will eat you and turn
you into a shrunken head.
I finally figured out what
the shrunken head was.
I'm watched a show on shrunken heads,
like the tradition of doing it.
Oh,
we only you do that.
You're lying around your house.
Like,
what will I entertain myself?
Was it,
no,
it was a total channel flip.
I'm not shrunk in it.
It was a total channel flipper.
I should,
it's creepy.
It's creepy as fuck,
man.
I was,
I was under the impression that
the scholars in there,
it's not,
they take the skull out and they're
basically shrinking the skin down to like
this leatherish smallest thing and then
they pull it in to make it like a little
purse out of it.
It's gangster as fuck.
I mean,
the shrunken head move is one of
the most gangster things ever.
You know,
they're not just going to
take your head and cut it off.
They're going to make a
little ornament with it.
A little.
Yeah.
It's a little leather ornament.
Wow.
What the fuck?
You know,
people who just never bothered like with
anything like books and fuck a book.
Okay,
we're here to make shrunken heads.
Well that was it.
Like,
you know,
like a,
television and the Internet,
you think about it.
Cause like back in the old days in
England and the way they tortured people,
you look at like torture instruments.
It was because they
didn't have television.
Yeah.
Like how are we going
to entertain herself?
Well,
that's funny because you know,
Biden is imposing or
encouraging,
endorsing,
proposing a tax on the
producers of violent movies.
Wow.
Violent movies,
Violent v media,
violent video games,
and they're considered,
they're considering imposing a tax,
a special tax on that.
I think the opposite.
I really believed this,
and this is not an
indictment on the human race.
I think naturally we're just a
little fucked up and chimpanzee like,
but I think that seeing things like
violent movies and violent video games are
probably like the most cathartic ways to
avoid doing those things in real life.
Like there's something that gets satisfied
without us having to actually go and
kill someone in a war.
That's one of the reasons why the most
passive people in the world are fucking
comic book nerds.
I mean,
who the hell wants to see damage and
destruction more that a comic book nerd
going to watch a hulk movie?
You go watch the hog and he's smashing
and destroying shit or wolverines
stabbing dudes with their fucking clause.
You know those guys well,
her to fly.
Right,
right,
right.
That's a really good point.
The average dudes were like really into
like heavy duty Psi Phi and heavy duty
action,
you know,
Scifi films,
those kind of Dudes,
like they don't,
they're not harming people.
It's,
I think there's a cathartic release and
being attached to extreme things without
have to actually participate in them.
That's a good point.
I mean,
and they should be concentrating on
making society better place and like
certain,
you know,
man,
some of the inequality and um,
you know,
uh,
class,
I think once you're fucked up already
a violence something or another,
any kind of violent media can
influence you and can excite you.
But the reality is you have to be that
you have to be fucked up for it to work.
And the idea of concentrating
on that as a cause,
it's not a cost that's causes
you've got a mental health issue.
Right.
That's the thing.
It should be,
we should be,
it should be more concerned
about people's mental health.
That Guy Andres Breivik,
the lunatic in Norway
that shot the island,
you know,
um,
he desensitized himself for a year.
He sat in his mom's basement
and I'd follow that.
I was obsessed with that trial and
that dude is so fucking sinister.
Um,
but he,
he's thought about shooting people
while he was doing it and then he would
desensitize himself that I wouldn't,
um,
you know,
his,
uh,
he could work past that consciousness
telling him not to do it.
So I mean,
that guy was just a sick fuck.
Yeah.
And not everybody that plays that,
millions of people probably played that,
uh,
you know,
world of war craft or
whatever the fuck he was into.
But yeah.
Yeah.
Only you can't blame that.
It's just doesn't work that way.
It's like blaming cars for crashing
into people and killing them.
It's not,
it's not,
the video game does make
be able people nuts.
You got nuts that are reacting to
video games and the way to solve that.
It's not taking away the video
games or tax of video games.
The way to solve that is find out what
the fuck is wrong with people that makes
them do that.
What is it?
What is it that makes a person
able to commit horrific acts?
Yeah.
I look at the dude in Cleveland.
He kept those girls,
you know,
he's torturing them and he's
raping them for like 10 years.
What,
what media was he until well,
magazines.
Was He reading?
You know what,
Eh,
um,
you know,
always life.
Yeah.
Well,
or I don't think it had
anything to do with that.
I think someone dehumanize him.
Probably a long time ago.
If someone raised him in
some horrific environment,
they created a monster,
right?
Somehow or another through circumstance,
nurture nature,
whatever.
You got a monster.
I'm more scared of ex military than I am
with people that play too much hardcore
video games.
And you should be,
yeah,
you should,
but you should be scared of
anybody who's taking life.
You know,
once you,
once you've taken
someone's life and done it,
you know,
and to a point where it's sanctioned.
Yeah.
It's,
it's problematic.
Not Everybody has a discipline,
the handle,
something like that.
You know,
a lot of that's,
you know,
it's admirable how many guys can be
disciplined to come back from that and be
okay.
But for a lot of people
know a lot of people,
it's just that that PTSD man is just
unbearable for a lot of those guys.
If they say that one of the best things
for PTSD is Mtma is a ecstasy and
they're having headway in,
um,
and doing that in,
in therapeutic,
uh,
with therapeutic applications of Mtma
and the helping people that have,
uh,
all sorts of PTSD,
post traumatic stress disorder
for people don't like acronyms.
That's telling me an acronym.
Is it,
is it an acronym like NASA,
when you say it,
that's an acronym,
right?
I don't know.
What is it when it's just like CIA,
you know,
you're not calling it Chia.
I can't spell restaurant.
Yeah.
Restaurant.
I rely on my iPhone for that.
I get to res to,
yeah,
man.
Remember when you used to have to fucking
write out a paper and turn it into
school?
You have to act.
You just have to write it out and
know how to spell each number.
One of those words.
Now I just get close and
it gives me a real load,
squiggly line to do a little right quick.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's what I was looking for.
You know,
I don't,
and that's all you need.
It's not like you need to know that.
It's kind of funny how
little you do know though.
It's Kinda funny how little,
you know,
like my eyes are going,
when I look at things like as
far as like the reach of my hand,
I'm fine,
but when I get close for whatever reason,
like reading things close,
it's just blurry.
It's fucked now.
And um,
when I,
when I see things like,
um,
I have to like find like
the place where it works.
Yeah.
Hipster glasses.
Dude.
I don't know why you don't do it.
I think glasses are cool.
If I could wear glasses,
I wear glasses every day.
I don't remember what my point was,
what we were talking about before I
went and says blessed the video games.
Torture people.
A soldier's seeing,
seen combat and have
an ecstasy treatments.
The shark that was found off the coast
of Huntington beach might be a road
record.
Why Spreaker shark?
Did you say shocked?
It was found or check this out.
It was caught off of,
oh Geez.
It's 11 foot shark was
caught Monday morning,
uh,
outside of Huntington
beach and Catalina Island.
The size of that fucking thing.
Yeah.
1000,
323 pounds.
What the fuck?
Wow.
Oh God damn it.
This guy's beard.
It is that,
that,
that world,
if that thing could fucking fly,
okay,
if sharks instead of swimming around,
wow,
the three d rounds,
if they could fly,
if they were on our world and they could
just fly around and eat people the way
they move through the ocean,
God damn.
Would it be scary?
The ocean is so much more fucked up.
That's why nothing ever gets done.
That's the shows that it's,
there's
a benefit like as far as progress to
having one intellectually superior species
that gets to control the food chain.
That gets to put a halt to all the
bullshit and then figure out things like
roofs and the Internet and cars.
Because if you can't keep
those things from eating you,
you wind up with the ocean where
no one ever builds a fucking house.
You're best.
Ocean is like a fucking
one of those crabs.
Hermit crabs.
They just scoot to the next
little shell and climb under it,
but that's,
shell only exists because somebody
eight whoever was living in it,
somebody found it and ate it and now
you're going to hide it in there.
You're going to fall.
You're going to hide
inside of his body cavity.
That's the ocean.
That's why there's,
there's no one that's phones in the ocean.
There's nothing gets done in there.
He just,
it's a constant move.
It's three d you can control things.
The thing that made us able to
rise above all the other animals,
so we are the control and
lockdown areas and put up fences.
We can keep things out,
can't keep anything
out in the ocean pitch.
The ocean is just the ocean.
It's just a wild brown bag and
there's no way to solve that.
So all the dolphins in the world,
you know,
as smart as they are,
it's supposed to be as smart as us.
They never figured out a fucking house.
They never figured out how to build some
shelter where they could just like get
I from tied to get eaten by sharks.
How you guys want to do this?
Let's make a house or something
like something with a shark.
Can't get through Barb wire.
They can't do it.
There's not enough time.
Keep moving.
Get more fish.
Go,
go,
go those Japanese bolts fucking rotten.
You should turn that into a bit.
That's brilliant.
Thanks.
Let's try and make,
make a note of that one.
That's brilliant.
That's a great bit.
Alright,
what did I say again?
What if for the future we had to
live underneath the ocean because we,
you know,
the air pollution or the weather or
something like that forces us to have to
build houses.
They would do that before outer space.
The atmosphere.
I mean you could be like,
you could say,
hey,
we need to build this house under ground
here instead of having to go up space.
Oh you forgot the ranch.
You have to come back.
Well,
we'd get lonely.
Yeah,
that'd be pretty bad ass though.
If like we all like our walls
were just like looking inside
under anything.
How much shit eats things
with its face in the ocean.
Just think of how crazy the ocean is.
It's just one big motherfucker trying
to eat a smaller motherfucker while I'm
even bigger.
Motherfucker tries to eat him.
Like that's one of the coolest things
about catching a fish and having an attack
by a shark while you're reeling in.
And have you ever had that happen?
No.
Reeling it in.
Wallin Shark is by yeah
me neither.
But it looks awesome.
That's something I'd like to experience
but I've seen guys do that and like deep
sea fishing,
like they catch a big tuna or something
like that and it has to bring in a
fucking shark.
Attacks it and tears it in half.
If you were seeing like the
pictures and the images online.
Yeah,
it's fucking fascinating cause
that's what the the ocean,
it's just just a fucking crazy
gangster fight with your face all day.
The biggest shit trying
to eat the biggest shit.
I mean a tuna is a bad motherfucker just
running around jacking smaller fish,
but not small.
Nope.
Shark comes along.
Jack's the tuna.
It's just a wild race.
We pulled the sharks out where
the top of the food chain,
I love when I lived in Holland,
the the symbol of the lottery in Holland
is a big fish eating a little fish.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's,
that's true to life.
You got money is big fish for a
little while till you're fucked.
Till the fucking shark comes along.
You crazy ass loses it.
I bet if you win the lottery,
I bet you were just immediately
assaulted by con people.
Yeah.
Bit Con Artists.
Just look for someone who won
the lottery and like this one.
The fucker.
Thanks buddy.
It comes easy.
I just talk him into investment.
I don't invest in a wonderful
investment on fraternity.
Don't go on television.
Don't,
don't hold.
don't take pictures of
you holding the big check.
Yeah.
Wonderful.
Wonderful opportunities.
Holding this money that
you think you deserve.
The whole idea of a lot of
these fucking ridiculous,
well they say the money was originally
supposed to go to education in this
country and then yeah,
none of it.
You know what they realized
the more educated people are,
the less likely that I
play the fucking lottery.
They'd be cutting their own feet.
Sold that United States
that the lottery thing.
Remember that does that way.
Yeah.
And as it went state by state
and gambling where it's allowed,
they always sell it to the public saying
that the biggest portion of this money
will go to education and
the schools and everything.
We've been broke for the less 10 20 years.
And you know,
where's that?
Where's that promise?
Nobody remembers the,
well it certainly should go to something
good cause you're just stealing money
from crazy people.
That's what you're doing.
You're giving people the chance to
throw money away in the very unlikely
possibility than my winsome.
And like,
it's like I grew up in Orlando and there's
the East West Expressway and it was a
toll road and they said when they built
it in the early eighties that once it
was paid for that take the tolls down,
but they never did it just now.
They raised the prices.
It's like that lottery casino thing.
It's like you can sell it to the people
and then they'll fucking forget 10 years
from now.
Once you establish that money's coming in,
it's very difficult to stop that.
Then no one ever likes to
bridge things free now.
Nobody ever has enough.
Especially
it's like nine bucks a pop,
like you go over the Gw.
I think in New York now it's like,
correct me if I'm wrong,
so I think it's like $9 or at
least it might even be more,
but every time you're going
there you're getting a hit.
When I was living there,
I think it was like seven 50 or
something like that and I was like,
this is insane.
Like every person that comes over this
bridge has to pay $7 just to get into the
city.
That's like some gangster shit,
you know,
because I lived in Boston and Boston,
you could take like toll roads
but you can also get to it.
Like there's ways to get where
you didn't have to pay anything.
You didn't,
if you didn't go on the mass turnpike,
like there's ways you can go
where he didn't have a toll,
but there's no way of getting a New
York City lets you paying somebody.
You want to take those
bridges from Staten Island,
you can pay me bitch,
you're coming in from Jersey,
pay me.
You got to pay to get in here dog.
It's like an,
it doesn't cost anything to leave.
It doesn't cost of live
in New York twice and uh,
deleted all of my funds and uh,
both times when I moved down in New York,
I,
as I crossed the free bridge,
I thought it doesn't
cost anything to leave.
Isn't that fascinating too?
Is it to regulate how many people come in?
Is it to mitigate traffic and to make
it like problematic because it cost so
much money?
Maybe a Carpool,
is that the idea?
To tell you a little story?
Sure.
Uh,
uh,
it is a big story actually,
and I was reminded of,
but you're talking about the George
Washington Bridge and when I was 20 years
old,
I lived in Washington heights for a year.
Worst Year of my life.
Why?
Just the worst year of my life.
I,
I wasn't ready as a comedian.
Oh,
how old were you?
20.
Oh,
yeah.
Yeah,
I'd only been doing it like three years.
I,
you know,
I didn't have been doing it three years
by the time we were just sweating.
I started at 17 Bates.
Where'd you start?
Orlando powerful.
And Lando produced a couple
of good things and uh,
uh,
anyway,
so
I always swore if I ever had any money
I would live in New York was style.
So when my Sitcom was finished,
a 98,
99,
I moved to New York City and I got a
rock star apartment in the Wall Street
area.
Oh,
you did not considered one of the first
skyscrapers ever built a 20 stories
tall.
It's at the entrance of a Wall Street.
The entrance of Wall Street.
It's Trinity Churches Right there.
Only on the 18th floor where
their marble balconies.
I had three marble balconies.
I was on this corner unit,
just pimp spot.
Oh my three blocks from
the World Trade Center.
Oh my goodness.
A 16 foot tall ceilings.
I could lie in my bed.
Look up at the World Trade Center.
It must've been,
it was,
it was fantastic.
But it was a time in my life,
you know,
the Sitcom had ended.
I,
I felt I was angry.
I was angry and I was,
I was,
I was searching for meaning and,
and uh,
what was important in life
and what was making you angry?
I just,
you know,
I had the Sitcom and it didn't
work out and then I just,
you know,
I wanted to just go focus on being
a comedian and live in New York.
So the Dalai Lama was going to give
a speech for free in central park on
happiness for six months.
I had the flyer on my refrigerator.
Nothing in the world was going to make
me miss the Dalai Lama's speech on
happiness.
So the night before,
I'm headlining at Caroline's on Broadway.
And there were these two Puerto Rican
lesbian strippers and they loved me and
they stuck around after the show and
they wanted to talk to me and where we're
talking.
And then they,
they invited me out with them.
And you know what,
uh,
there was the queen
bee and the other girl,
the other girl was off limits
because she had a boyfriend.
I ain't give a fuck about the other girl.
It was all about the queen bee and the
other girl was in love with the Queen Bee
cause she was making all the,
all the decisions and
making everything happen.
Wow.
So who's she?
The Queen Bee had a car.
We're driving down to
the village somewhere.
Uh,
they said they had ecstasy.
Do I want to do ecstasy?
And I'm like,
hell yeah.
We go to some lounge and we're
drinking Pinot Grigio on ice.
And I had never had Pinot
Grigio and my night to this day,
I love Pinot Grigio cause it
reminds me of this evening.
It's a perfect,
uh,
you know,
like red wine is an autumn winter thing.
Uh,
but,
but a dry white wine,
like a Pinot Grigio is great in summer.
So we're in,
you know,
we're drinking and we're
having a great time.
And,
uh,
you know,
after about an hour,
this ecstasy starts
thumping and this girl,
the queen bee wanted to
go to some dance club.
We go to some dance club in Soho.
It's packed.
I didn't want to be a packed dance club.
I want to be with these girls.
She knew the DJ.
We get up these steps were in
this private area behind the DJ.
No one can see us,
the Djs like 10,
15 feet in front of it,
just like jamming and the place is
packed downstairs but you can't see them.
And we got this horse shoe leather couch
and we're just racking and she's got
more bottles of Pinot Grigio on ice and
we're just fucking dancing and grinding
on each other.
And we go back to my apartment and
about five o'clock in the morning,
something like that.
And,
you know,
we dance on my furniture and
we'll play music and stuff.
And we got in my bed and
honestly there was no sex.
Uh,
we had our bottoms underwear on and
it was so tender and just resting and
kissing and tasting of fleshing
and touching of private areas.
And the,
at one point the queen bee got up on
her knees and she starts French kissing
this other girl and
she's rubbing her mound.
What?
She's just kissing her.
And I got behind this,
uh,
behind the Queen Bee and I just start
kissing this big beautiful brown bulbous
acid.
Mm hmm.
I got my hands up on the top curvature
of it and I pulled her panties aside,
them stuck my nose in her honey pot and
I'm just tasting these delicious flesh
rose petals and um,
I overslept and I missed the Dalai Lama's.
You when
you win,
why would you,
why would you even think that
that would be a bad thing?
The Dalai Lama joke,
it's a true story,
but it's not a joke.
It's actually a true story story.
The Dalai Lama represents a,
an interesting point
of view and that's it.
You know the idea that this guys you guys
guy for to find out what happiness is,
the eye,
it's the idea of a one,
a one figurehead like that is kind of
preposterous to the idea of enlightenment.
The idea,
especially if you're dealing with a guy
who dresses like a wizard and doesn't
fuck,
he doesn't get to have sex.
He's never had sex.
I mean he could if he wanted to,
but he thinks that it complicates that.
I feel bad the Dalai Lama because
Richard Gere always
wants to hang out with,
you can see the Dalai Lama like a
pulling Richard Gere aside one day going,
hey Richard,
you ever considered Scientology?
Whatever.
I had to imagine the conversations the
Dalai Lama must have with like Sharon
Stone or he's like,
yeah,
I can't believe they chose her either.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
look,
yes,
a lot of movies,
but you're amazing and base against tank.
I thought you were amazing and the,
they didn't think you could
pull it off in the second one.
You pulled it off in the second one.
Did you see this basic instinct too?
It's a horror movie.
It changed from,
it changed from an erotic film
when Sharon Stone was young too.
Uh,
like uh,
like a panic moment.
Solid.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
I did Sun.
I'm a diligent worker when it comes to
watching stupid shit that I might be able
to make fun of.
She's in it.
Right?
But she was like 50 and I'm not joking.
She show anything like that nipple,
the whole leg thing.
But there's a feeling that you get when
a 50 year old woman who's trying like
really hard to be sexy.
Like I dunno if she was
directed in that way,
but when you're 50 you
realize by the time you 50,
he realize it's mostly all bullshit.
Okay,
what are we doing here?
You know,
if we're going to fuck,
we're going to fuck.
But all of this like sultry shit that
you might get away with when you're 20.
It's because you,
you're,
you're a a spell when you're 20.
When a woman is in her young twenties.
She the reason why they have
this idea of themselves,
it's so inflated like really beautiful
girls is because they're like magic.
Like you were around them and
get like your mood changes,
you draw towards them,
you soften your personality though
or were pick it up or whatever.
You need to get me the
lucky a little bit more.
It's like a drug.
It's like a fascinating orotic draw.
But then when they get 50 and
they're still doing the same thing,
then it's like,
oh shit,
what's wrong with her?
Oh fuck.
So when you see across her leg,
just like the real moment of panic where
I would think about me in my younger
days,
if I was in that scenario,
I would,
I would say,
okay,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
It was that moment,
50 year old lady shows you her gapper
and then closes the legs over and you're
like,
nope,
got gotta go right now I am going right.
That is not the way
like a healthy sexually,
you know,
confident 50 year old
woman would would fuck you.
I can't believe they
just had her do it again.
That's so lame and seeing over two lanes.
Oh,
sorry.
It was so unnecessary,
you know,
I mean,
what's Hollywood unnecessary ideas?
Well,
well,
I think it's like someone who's never
done standing up trying to craft a joke on
this is going to work.
You know,
you don't really have a chance to vet it.
You just have to put it out there as
a movie and hope that people get it.
And the first basic jeans to
instinct was really fucking,
you know,
it was well received.
It wasn't the best movie in the world,
but it was kinda fun.
It's,
you know,
it's took your,
your interest and she's sexy as fuck,
man.
Old Sharon Stone
is sexy as fuck that we'll
miss suck structurally.
Perfect,
beautiful,
beautiful woman and a powerful actress.
But when you're 50,
keep,
keep your gabber shut.
What else did she do?
She didn't,
she didn't done anything lately.
I don't know.
She does liver,
liver,
liver.
That was quite awhile ago.
I think she did that one thing where
they were interviewing her about,
uh,
the earthquake in China.
And she said that she believed,
she said,
well maybe it's Karma for what they do
to Tibet cause I'm friends with the Dalai
Lama's,
my friend.
And it's like she had to apologize for it.
I think it cost her like one of
her perfume things or something.
But that's just such a crazy way of
thinking that a bunch of random strangers
that did it.
Huge March man.
That's a huge market.
You go over there and it's funny,
you go to Europe,
you go to China and you see like huge
actors that are doing commercials but they
would never do in the states.
Japan,
right.
Pick Japan also.
But China and uh,
what Deniros like on some
coffee thing in Italy,
Robert Deniro,
he's a like symbol of this.
Some little espresso.
That's hilarious.
Wow.
That's so weird.
Yeah.
Well I think it's just like Leonardo
Dicaprio does commercials and like Japan
and
I think,
I don't believe that you
should take anybody's getaway.
If they fuck up and say something stupid,
people can be ultimately say back the
truck up and grabbed the money baby.
Cause they said something stupid.
I mean,
she said a stupid thing.
She probably didn't mean it.
It's probably didn't realize how
fast your heads so far up in her ass.
And she had her little buddy,
the Dalai Lama,
to be impressed that she
stood up to mean China.
China is awesome.
Just stupid is a really cool place,
man.
Well,
I'm sure China is awesome.
I haven't been,
but these are just people.
There's people that died in an earthquake.
It's Karma because we massive too.
It's like saying,
you know what I mean?
Look,
the United States is a massive place.
Like,
you know,
something happens somewhere.
It's just,
you know,
uh,
we're a big landmass it China.
Well,
it's,
and again,
it's the people who died didn't have
anything to do with anything that happened
to Tibet.
So how the fuck is it Karma?
It's,
are you saying,
is that in your vision that the
emperor is the overlord and you know,
he really does have all the people
under his spell and they're,
they're responsible for his actions as
well.
Because these are just regular folks.
I was just in New Zealand and
the Dalai Lama is coming there.
He's,
I think he's there right now.
Does he knows where that road is?
Doing a little toy.
Yeah,
he does.
He's doing a little tour,
but he wears them a red
lace lingerie underneath it.
Um,
he's hotlist still in like Auckland and
Christchurch and Dun Eden and it's the
happiness thing.
So I mean that was when I,
that was like 99 when my story happened.
So that guy still doing the same act,
pushing that happiness show work.
Nobody's happy.
He's saying the way to be happy as a
dress like a wizard and don't fuck,
I'm not buying,
buying it.
We get head.
I guess.
It's just seems like you're wasting it.
I Get a light saber.
I'm not wearing the robe.
It seems like you would want
someone to make love to,
whether it's a man or a woman would
want someone gets cold at nights,
but it's also fun.
It's a part of life.
It's a part of life is expressing
affection through your body feels good.
You know,
it's recreational as well.
you're going to exercise.
It's great when people say,
well,
you know,
recreational sex isn't healthy.
We can have recreational sex.
You can.
It can be done.
People have done it forever.
It's shut up just because
you can't handle it.
People have,
it's not,
it's just touching bodies together
better.
When you get older though,
like dude,
the girls finally go,
Oh yeah,
we could just have casual sex.
You know,
I'm 35 again.
The American women,
women in different countries
have different heads,
completely different
attitudes and it's shocking.
It's shocking.
You go to,
you know,
you in European countries,
they're so likable,
like much more like man,
like man,
they fucked like men.
Like they want to do it all the time too.
It was like a lot of American women.
It's like,
oh,
I'm going to break him off a
piece every once in a while.
I like it.
I like their dog treats or something.
Okay,
here's a guy you did good.
You know you've washed the cars and
take out the trash and cut the grass.
All right,
here's,
here's your dog treat man.
I'm euro trash.
So weak.
I just think
did,
it's probably because the
people that came over here,
like the very first wave periods there.
Yeah.
And I think that that,
that initial run,
that initial thing that started off
this country somehow or another,
a fiber of it's still fucking sticks
and there's a lot of slut shaming and
there's a lot of like weak,
angry people that are like pointing
fingers and shaming someone for enjoying
something a day.
Enjoy as well.
You know,
like slut shaming.
That's the,
that is all Douche bags.
Any guy that like you like rails on a
girl because she wants her exact term slut
shaming.
Yeah,
man.
That's what it is.
It's like a guy's a stud.
If he goes out here,
we went out to King Kune.
We had sex with two different girls,
different girls every day.
It was crazy.
Wow.
My guts and nuttiest weekend ever.
But if a girl tells you she fuck
two different guys for a week,
you below can a fucking whore.
He probably gonna get aids.
You gotta give it to my brother.
Oh fuck you bitch.
You know what I mean?
It's like it's,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
People should be able to deal with
ever the fuck they want to do.
But so for some women they know that
that backlash and not just from,
from men,
but that backlash from women too because
if women are out there giving it up,
you know,
like that's fucking horse.
She'll just fuck anybody,
you know.
She's never going to get fucking married
cause she just fuck salary money.
Those kind of women had to
make the world go round.
They do.
You need them all right.
They keep a lot of guys happy.
Well you don't,
so you need,
I think that would be a lot of that.
A lot less savage killers and,
and a fucking lunatics in this country.
If you know a women were fucking more,
you know,
these are dudes,
what would help a lot.
Just a little,
just a little more,
you know,
legalized floods in general.
There you guys,
prostitution would help a,
I think [inaudible]
pos.
If you managed legalize prostitution,
I think it probably lower the crime rate.
I really do.
I mean it's theoretical.
Don't go like fucking
citing me as a study.
Holland does it and the,
the women have to be tested
every like six months and it's a,
they pay taxes as well.
It's,
you know,
did you see those two women that were
retiring than it fucked for like 50 years?
When was that?
Did you see that?
Oh my God.
Hello?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I didn't want to shame them
so let's not show their,
for their images.
But the,
anyway,
the point of news item,
it was so depressing.
They just fucked anybody who
came through the door for like
50 years.
The Amsterdam girls are twin sisters.
They just retired.
They just sat in the window for like
the last 50 years that their oldest
prostitutes and answer,
how's a Wowza?
Yeah,
it's a different week.
I think we have to recognize
that we have a version of how,
how society is,
but the,
the rest of the world,
which is also exactly like
us as far as like technology,
civilization,
laws,
money,
exact them.
I mean basically you're,
you're in Europe.
Their systems are different,
you know,
the,
the languages are different,
but everything is modern.
You know,
if you're in,
if you're in Montreal,
Canada or if you're in Berlin,
everything is super modern right now.
There's only,
it's everything is like we live in a
time where like there's never been like
more equality as far as like uh,
access to information.
Right.
We all,
we all have the same tools.
I mean if you have,
if you can afford some
certain basic things,
you know,
computer
yeah.
As far as like in information.
But as far as money,
it's probably like the widest gap ever.
Isn't that weird?
It's like as far as money,
like there's like a small
core group like the,
well you know when they call them one
percenters who have most of the money and
then everybody else.
That's kind of fascinating.
You would think that maybe
eventually that trend will even out,
you know,
cause it seems like the only
way if you looked at it,
and this is obviously not,
not looking at the system logically or
even educated with an educated opinion of
this financial system.
But if you looked at it logically
and you step back and you saw,
well,
okay,
this 1% has all this money,
but how much access to
information is there?
Oh,
it's not totally transparent yet.
Hm.
Well,
when it becomes transparent,
these 99% are going to realize how these
1% got so much fucking money and they
got to go,
wow,
you can't do that.
And then everyone's going to agree.
Yeah,
they can't do that.
Right?
No,
they can't do that.
Jesus fucking Christ who let them do that.
That's when there's 100% accountability
when you're going to be able to beat
you.
Absolutely.
Sure.
What someone has and hasn't done.
That's common.
You think so?
I don't think they'll ever be that
transparency where you can see that,
I think workings of the
1% I think it's gonna.
I think,
I think they've got,
they've mastered the game.
They got,
you know,
the houses in Switzerland or
wherever the fuck they live.
And,
but I think technology is
the biggest fear to that.
The big arrive on the
building on a helicopter pad.
You don't have to,
you know,
even being in an elevator
with the underclasses,
but what I'm saying is I don't think
they're going to be able to maintain it
anymore because like where's,
where's your money?
Where is it?
Zero zero box so you can go to,
no,
it's all ones and Zeros.
I'm computers now.
Your money is essentially
just a confidence game.
It's like what do you have to you?
The things that you
bought with that money,
but that money's just like set sitting
somewhere like it's either in stacked in
bills,
which is equally brie weird.
You do a bunch of notes and that's it.
That's your mind.
What happens to the burns
need to have nothing.
What did what,
where's the value?
Like what is this?
You can't replace them.
Say,
Hey,
I burnt my 1 million notes.
Can you give me a new notes?
You don't have them numbered off like
a fucking hotel key that you lose.
You don't have a scrooge duck room where
you roll around and your gold coins.
If I was Joe Rogan perfect
a room just a little bit,
you know,
just a couple of grand
you could go roll around,
make it rain on yourself.
I think the more information comes out,
the more access,
the more control the average
person has over their own domain,
the less likely you're going to have 1%
of the people with most of the wealth
doesn't make any sense.
Does it?
Seems like that's not how
the people would let it be.
They'd figure out a way around that
like that seems like that's obviously
someone's exploited the system and
they've made it a non unfair competition.
Like this isn't like an
even exchange anymore.
You're getting this insane amount of
revenue as opposed to the rest of the
population.
If you look at it like this massive group
of bankers and Destria it's like well
this is an insane amount of money.
There's only 50 you fuck heads.
Like hold on and you all partied together
and wife swap and you have fucking key
parties and shit.
They're like air force pilots.
They're out.
They're just flying until
they run out of gas.
Going full gangster.
Making billions like that.
Bernie Madoff cock sucker when they,
within the snag that fighter pilots,
they're like fucking full games runs out.
They know that as soon as like there's
some wiki leaks for the whole world and
we as soon as everything like it's full
100% transparency and then ultimately
voting on the Internet that's
going to kill them all.
One world government
voting on the Internet,
one when no government
it's going to be where it's at because
it's going to get to a point where people
are going to realize that they're in
in order to keep everybody from being
crazy,
there has to be a balance
and until you bounce it out,
people are going to be crazy
because he's going to be an equity.
You just going to be people that are
eating fucking dirt sandwiches and then
people that have thrown and half their
food away because they're lazy and fat
and they just take for granted that their
foods at the store in the morning when
they get up and I think that that until
until you get that balance is out.
There's always going to be some chaos.
There's always that to like,
and the
only way that's going to balance out
is if everybody has free access to
resources.
It's like a non capitalist idea.
It's a stupid idea because the reason why
capitalism works is because it rewards
effort and effort is what creates things.
You know,
the harder you work,
the more reward you get,
the more you become a baller.
But the problem is a lot
of those ballers they go,
hmm,
I like working but I don't
like working this hard.
How about if I just rig this thing?
So it just continues to make me money
even though it doesn't make any sense and
no one's gonna say anything
cause I'm the rich guy.
Randy,
you go and that's basically
what the fuck happened.
It has to be rectified.
That has to be,
we have to be put in
a situation where our,
our,
the way we conduct our lives,
whether it's finance or
government or just behavior,
the way we communicate with each other,
it makes sense for the information that
we have in front of us in 2013 and the
fucking,
the stock market does not make sense with
the information that we have in front
of us.
In 2013 it looks like
a crazy chaotic ride.
People screaming at each other on the
floor and it's going up and down and a
buzzer when rings off.
You've got to stop the trades at a
certain time like what the fuck are you
doing?
What are you doing?
Hollering and writing shit down and
throwing paper at each other and screen.
What is the system?
What do you,
are you manipulating it or
you're calling it as it happens?
What's it based on?
Is it based on anything tangible?
Is it just confidence?
Is it just,
can you get a bad rumor out there and
crash your stock and then everybody loses?
What the fuck did you lose?
What was out there.
That's a
right and our whole system is tied to it.
Guys have a bad day and we all go in the
toilet and I know there's people like
you don't understand the financial system.
And that's their ignorance
that you show on the show.
It was disgusting.
I'm so fucking tired
of your pseudo science,
right?
You're right.
You're right on all accounts.
Wall Street always reminds
me of the Middle East.
It's always a bunch of unshaven assholes
yelling at the top of their lungs.
I had some friends from back in
Boston that went into stock markets.
They went into doing that and it's uh,
they were,
they were savages,
man.
They were like crazy
adrenaline junkie savages.
And they wound up being
the stock market guys.
They wound up being,
uh,
being dudes on the floor
screaming and yelling.
What is it called?
An agent.
What do they call them?
A floor dude.
What do they call the dorks?
Traders know a trader.
It's trader trader.
The guys on the floor with the pets.
It's crazy system.
I don't understand it,
but where I lived around Wall Street,
those,
those a lot,
a lot of little late night diary
with bars all around and all this,
they're all down there.
When I was there a system that that
could be created where money made sense,
where like the finances made sense.
Where like,
I guess like as soon as
the company goes public,
like just that alone,
the ability to buy stock in a company
and bank that the company does well,
and if it does well your profit,
if it doesn't go well,
isn't that gambling?
Is that,
it seems like gambling to me.
Right?
Is it a kind of gambling?
It kind of is.
It is,
right?
Yeah.
How come?
Oh,
hi.
Is that legal?
How can the stock market's like,
didn't,
okay.
Like here,
how about Bernie Madoff?
Obviously what he did was illegal.
Right?
But like,
why isn't that like,
do you think he's,
do you think right now,
every day he's gobbling
balls with his asshole.
Oh,
he got balls.
Certainly paid the word enough to,
uh,
you know,
stakes to the guys who,
uh,
do you think he gets fucked?
Oh,
I think he's just getting pounded.
You fucked a lot of people.
A lot of people,
a lot of really wealthy people.
It's amazing.
Like children,
some like some like children's
cancer fund or something.
Some,
a few really important charities and shit.
Yeah,
he had somebody in,
it's connected in that jail then.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
I'm sure he's,
he was a real sociopath to that guy.
Apparently when they arrested him,
he didn't fucking crack a sweat.
Nothing like,
Yep.
All right,
let's go.
Like he knew it was coming and then when
they tore apart his business and then
realize that what he had done,
he showed no remorse.
He's like,
I'm hungry.
I need something to eat.
You know?
Like it was like,
oh wow.
He was not,
he slept well.
He never worried about
those people in the,
the,
the kind of intense,
intense fucking pain that he caused.
All of those people,
he stole money from you.
They didn't give a fuck.
Well,
he was just a sociopath
just done by this system.
It's amazing.
Then he pulled it off.
That's what's amazing.
What's amazing is that the system is
so wonky that a guy can just pretend to
have money and not really,
and just fucking do this
weird thing where you're
move shit around card Monte with millions
of dollars with their money and look
you're which now you're making more money.
That's just incredible.
I am making more money.
The more money keep it and
the more money you make,
I'll just tell you that right now.
Okay,
I'm the fucking push it all in and so all
of a sudden this asshole disappears on
you or,
or winds up on CNN and you're like,
no,
I,
we were going to play tennis on Thursday.
You know there had to be at
least one dude who is suspicious.
Like,
man,
I think this dude's a cruck.
They had to be one dude.
But
he was just getting those,
those monthly checks and he's like,
it looks good.
Looks good here,
looks good.
Fuck.
It's just looking at those numbers like,
look,
I'm making money.
I mean
just as long as I keep my money in play,
I'm making money.
I'm just going to honey,
listen,
if we push all of our life
savings just together,
we go in for two years as
two out of 25% return rate,
which was put up in getting
and all of sudden CNN,
that ugly cont walking across the floor
of the courthouse and you'll like,
no,
he stole it.
How can that guy get away with that?
How has it,
obviously he didn't get away with it,
but how did he do it for so long?
What kind of system do you have?
This system is crazy.
You need a new Gundam system.
I agree.
What to do,
what to do,
Tom Rhodes as a world traveler.
What do,
because you're the guy,
what do we do?
You know,
my thoughts are childish,
man.
I think,
you know,
the invention of pockets
ruined everything.
I think we were happy when we were
just naked running around on the beach,
just eating fruit and fucking,
and then when somebody invented pockets,
hi,
I'm going to look at that
shiny Shell and Oh look,
a pretty rock.
And then you start getting all these
objects in your pocket and then you start
trading with other people.
And then like somebody invents,
you know,
paper money and Oh my God,
then you know,
I think you're right.
Fucking pockets.
Pockets ruined everything,
man.
I think you're right.
But I also think it's just the stage.
We just have to get used to this,
this,
this level of existence.
You just have to get used to it.
And pocket tourist and
he used to material,
you have to get used to the managing
your obsession with material objects,
you know?
But it could be managed.
It's still better to have him.
So way better.
It happens.
That's what I like about traveling and
not living anywhere is I accumulate a lot
less shit.
Oh yeah.
I just don't buy it.
I mean,
I have my essentials,
you know,
and the things I have,
they're the best,
you know,
don't ever ha you don't have a home base.
No.
So you literally,
you don't have a place where
you recharge for a week.
No.
And I,
I get my mail sent somewhere,
it said,
uh,
yeah.
So you're just hoteling
it everywhere you go.
It depends where I'm at,
you know?
Um,
uh,
well my sister was going
through cancer treatments that,
you know,
brought our family closer together
and went to Florida more often.
Uh,
you know,
last summer I did two months all over
Europe and then I had a week off and
rented an apartment in Rome.
Oh.
So,
uh,
and then last November I finished
a a month in Asia and uh,
me and my wife went to
Bali for like two weeks.
So it depends on where we're at.
Well,
like going to New Orleans a lot,
like when to Austin a lot,
you know,
just do you book yourself?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You do everything yourself now.
Everything.
Oh Wow.
So you don't use an agent or anything?
That's so smart art
at this point.
Why wasn't,
they didn't forge relationships
with the international people?
I mean,
I went to those places so you know why
he let some guys send an email and get
10%,
you know,
and then I've been doing my own stuff
in the states for like the last five
years.
And do you try to do
things other than stand up?
He just kind of tried to
concentrate on just trying to,
you know,
I,
I've,
I've got a podcast,
uh,
I'm trying,
I'm shooting videos all the time.
I,
you know,
I was trying to sell this
comedy travel show idea.
Now I've heard,
you know,
some kind of things similar to
that are being made and stuff.
So,
I don't know,
I just,
uh,
I'm just,
I'm just trying to make as much
art as I can while I'm alive,
you know,
and just fucking jokes,
videos,
podcasts.
I want to,
uh,
I've been,
you know,
writing for the Huffington posts,
like travel stuff,
but that,
I want to get my,
I've got a great stories.
I mean,
you know,
the Puerto Rican honeypot,
that's a good story,
baby.
So I'm going to get a book together,
you know,
I'm just,
I'm just a one man comedy art machine
and I'm just trying to fucking,
you know,
are you going to store your book in the,
but you going to have
it on you at all times.
You're gonna store it in the cloud.
What do you mean on your computer?
You know when you send
things up to the cloud,
cause I mean that's more appropriate.
Your,
your,
your ideas should be out there on a server
somewhere where you're roaming across
where everybody can,
the countryside.
No,
it's not an everybody can,
they're password protected.
Yeah,
we did actually have a hard copy.
Like some laptops,
they don't have much storage on them.
Like a lot of things people are storing.
All right.
They actually pulling
things down from the cloud,
which the problem with that is that you
have to have an internet connection.
No,
and that's the thing I got,
I got I,
me and my wife,
she's a photographer.
We both have extra hard drives.
We've got,
you know,
right.
I got like three hard drives to
travel with and just whip stuff on it.
And you know that we're filming
and recording and everything.
Before,
before the big asteroid hit,
everyone probably had their shit on the
cloud and that's why I wouldn't try,
I wouldn't trust putting something
that's recipe for disaster.
Yeah.
I mean look papers,
pretty good recipe for disaster to,
yeah.
I mean even the,
the oldest versions of the Bible,
the Dead Sea Scrolls that were
actually written on animal skins,
like they,
they,
uh,
that's like,
they have like little pieces of shit.
They try to piece together
because it doesn't last.
And that's,
that's the only like four or 5,000 years
old or 4,000 something around there.
I think maybe even a little older.
But that mean,
think about how long,
how long would a book lasts?
Probably wouldn't even last
as long as a piece of leather,
you know,
a piece of leather that you're writing
on probably last longer than the book
does.
So like,
I mean,
how many,
you know,
how many years would a book last?
We got to go back to rock and what the
fuck are you going to do with little
tiny,
you know,
SD cards,
you've got an SD card and that's
where you're storing all your shit.
You know,
like what does,
who's going in the future?
They're going to find that guy.
What the fuck is this?
Yeah.
Well,
I wonder what that is now for us.
Like arrowheads were like
what the fuck is that?
Imagine if it was like some Avatar Shit.
Not only was it an arrowhead,
it was also like you put it on the right
stone and it would glow and you'd get
tuned into her mother Gaia
and most arrowheads just had porn on it.
Terror attack cause
getting fucked by chicks.
That movie Avatar was so
that movie Avatar was
so fascinating to me.
Not just because I loved the movie but
because of all those people that got
avatar depression.
Oh yeah.
Live in up in the thing.
No the people,
the people who watched it,
they got an Avatar depression cause they
wish their life was as noble and real
as the Navi.
Wow.
Yeah.
It was really fascinating because it was
like a condition that was like getting
repeatedly diagnosed.
They were calling an avatar
depression half tongue and cheek,
but in half not,
I think that's just a brilliant marketing
move for the Blue Ray release Avatar.
You might be right.
Yeah.
That's probably driving
marketing bullshit.
Oh
well as far as like a overcoming
like obvious fakes on the Internet,
he's like the master at spotting
bullshit on the Internet.
I'd never met anybody who's got,
I don't think we're ever write any
of its river right all the time.
But you are like as far as
like videos or pictures,
you're like 99%
well you know what I've been finding out
a lot lately is a new one and I don't
know if this is mostly probably
just based in Los Angeles,
but there's these guys that go to
parties that act like normal people,
but they have to do something like,
all right.
I'm like,
I know somebody that got fired game.
Yeah,
I know some of that got hired to go.
All right,
you're a meth head and you need to go
to the bathroom like every five minutes
and just make it be obvious at the
party and you just kind of be normal.
But just kind of like the big be sweaty
and stuff like they just invite like
situations to parties like this.
So it's like a Gig for actors.
It's good for actors.
Yeah.
That's good.
Could you imagine you have a party and
some asshole hires a comic or an actor to
come over and pretend that he's a
method and it keeps like slamming your
bathroom door and putting on a show and
he's actually getting paid to do that.
But you know the guy and
he's done a really good actor
and halfway through
minutes and you're like,
what are you doing man?
I take,
cause you gotta sell the scene.
You've got to say you to believe it.
You've got to believe her.
The message,
you're not doing math right now man.
You're not,
I don't know if I'm crazy.
No,
no you're not.
There was also a,
he a guy that does like overly gay
at party where he's just super,
super gay and he's a real gay guy but
he does overly gay and they really,
they rent them out.
It's just a spice up parties cause you're
not like some parties are just like,
we're all just people who don't have
comedy and I'm to do things like they need
to,
they need to hire colorful
characters in real life.
It's hard to find good
conversation out there in America.
It's hard.
You know,
you could look upon the wrong fucking
little little corner of the world and be
stuck on this little circular.
What are those things called?
At the end of driveways,
the end of a road called the sac,
you can be caught to call the sack with
two boring motherfuckers and they just,
I was cotton called a sack with two
dummies to dummies in one really nice guy
who was strange but to
just straight dummies.
I just kind of what a dog.
Okay.
And his dog was like this creepy dog.
It was always out.
He didn't really have a fence.
He had a sort of little fence,
but there was a hill so the dog could go
up the hill and around the fence there
was no fence was bullshit,
you know?
And his dog was creepy.
Like you'd go out of the dog,
would growl at you and shit.
And he bit bit somebody who
was over the guy's house.
It was painting.
And so I love dogs.
I mean,
I fucking love dogs.
I've had dogs my whole life.
So when I think a dog,
it's creepy.
It's because I know it's erratic.
You know it's not,
I have a deep love for dogs.
So I,
I went to this dude's house and I'm like,
Hey,
I'm,
I go the dog.
I go,
he's,
he's not just getting out,
man.
I go,
he's like really being
aggressive and he's ground,
like maybe want like
want to look into this?
And so he goes,
yeah,
your,
your dog got out and attack me.
He just makes up a story about my
dog getting out and attacking him.
I'm like,
yeah,
are you okay?
Like what happened?
Many times nine,
he was 90 pounds a night at 90 pound dog,
the ones to attack it was a pit
bull that wants to attack you.
That's not going to,
you're not going to survive that.
And if you do survive that,
you're going to be horribly torn apart
me and might be able to get to a fence
and shut it.
Well,
I don't think he's going to let go.
I think he's gonna just tear you apart.
I really don't see you survive in that.
So when you,
you're a fat guy who smoked cigarettes
and you're telling me my dog attacked you
and you held him down by his neck.
This guy was telling me,
I held him down by his Nafta,
Tali,
calm down.
I go,
oh,
he calmed down.
Would that take a year?
You can not hold a pit bull down by the
neck and they're going to calm down.
Do you know anything about dogs?
You out of your fucking mind?
Like this is the dumbest story ever.
But I got sad because I was like,
this guy is,
this is his reality.
His reality is instead of dealing with
these problems and they're like going,
hey,
you know,
we've got to put this crazy dog down.
Let's talk.
It's going to bite somebody.
It's dogs.
Creepy sounds wrong with our dog.
Instead of that,
he's just putting blinders
on and making up stories.
And that's,
you could,
you could be that guy.
You could be putting blinders
on and making up stories.
Anybody can be that guy.
Make up your reality as
it's going little bit.
So that was my fucking neighbor and I'd
see that fucking dummy every day and
you'd ask me stupid
questions about stupid shit.
That's why you never
talked to your neighbors,
man.
I do not follow those rules.
I live next to the golf
fencer guys that go to it,
like renaissance festivals and,
and like,
they seem like nice people,
but I don't want to go in that world.
I don't want them to now like knock
on my door went and just like,
Hey,
what do you do in Brian?
I don't want any of that.
I don't want any
conversations with anybody.
Yeah.
I moved into my house 10
years ago when my neighbor,
like the moment I moved in,
they started sending these notices that
they wanted me to cut my trees down.
They wanted me to cut my tree so that
they could see like some lights in the
distance,
you know,
from behind.
You know,
like we're,
I guess if you see through my
trees you could see some lights.
They wanted me to chop the trees down.
Like,
like just right when I move in.
Not,
not.
Here's a cupcake that my wife baked.
Welcome to the neighborhood.
You know,
hey,
we're going to be sharing space together
on this plan and I'd like to shake your
hand and say,
you know,
and you ever need to
borrow a cup of sugar.
I'm right over here.
Yeah,
that would be nice.
Right now instead of this Dickhead,
once it bring me in front of some
homeowners association of a reason why,
one of the reasons why I bought
the house is the beautiful trees.
I love trees.
Chop them down so he could see the lights.
No.
When I do finally find
where I want to live,
there ain't going to be
no homeowners association.
All everything.
Homeowner's associations
are always assholes.
Yeah.
They tried to tell my friend that he
couldn't put a solar up in his yard and he
was like,
why can't I put solar up in my yard?
And they,
you know,
they say like,
oh,
it's on slightly in this thing,
but there's a California state law.
It says that homeowner's associations
can not stop you from putting up solar
power if you're,
if you're a smart person,
you have the shackles,
which I'm not smart
because I haven't done it,
but you're,
if you're not like having your
house hooked up solar in California,
this is the greatest resource we have.
We're so low on resources
here except for sunlight,
sunlight.
We have a massive abundance of it and
you can power your whole fucking easy
peasy with,
with solar in this
country or in this state,
rather.
It's so easy.
You know,
if you're in Seattle,
it's going to be a bitch.
But you know what I found
when you're in Seattle,
we were in the fucking woods man,
and this dude had solar panels on the
roof of his car and it's raining and it's
gloomy and drew this.
This solar panels still pull solar power.
Even when it's gloomy.
Even in Seattle,
they're still pulling and charging
is batteries and he was watching TV.
It's fucking crazy awesome at some,
I mean that that's,
we've been hoodwinked,
you know,
into thinking that that's not
a good way to get your energy.
Especially around here.
It's the best way to get your energy.
I had a pot growing friends
who used to live in Ukiah.
Ukiah is amazing.
It's like an hour north of San Francisco.
Woo.
Mendocino county looks
like Switzerland up there.
Beautiful Hasan.
And uh,
this guy loved,
we'd so much,
he had his own pot farm,
but he,
uh,
you know,
the DEA would,
they look for big patches.
He,
he would plan them in little
bunches along tree lines and he,
he loved,
we'd so much he got out there with a
shovel and Doug put in a sprinkler system
or it was timed and you know,
and he was totally living off the grid.
He had,
um,
you know,
big things that caught rainwater.
He,
you know,
whatever.
And then he had solar panels on his roof.
Guy Who completely lived
off the grid and everything.
Wow.
And uh,
he had a heart attack and died
like two years ago out there.
Yeah.
Good.
That's a good way to go.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
I miss,
yeah,
I mean,
he was
living off the grid,
living like a man collecting rain water.
And you know what I mean?
If you're going to go out there in the
wilderness where it's beautiful and
you're with nature and you
pass on to the next dimension,
that's,
that's a good way to do it.
Good.
Okay.
I would selfishly missed my
friend and when I visited him,
he'd give me like a pound of weed and I
would drive back to Los Angeles with my
cruise control set on 54
I'm going 54 right.
So terrifying.
We've got weed in your car and your dry.
Oh,
it's a terrifying feeling.
And we're so,
it's so lax here in California.
I have friends that live in California,
but then they do gigs other places and
they'll forget like if you get busted
with weed in Texas,
right.
They arrested Willie Nelson.
Right.
You know Willie fucking nails.
They're state icon.
Yeah.
Got,
might as well be your grandfather.
You're going to rest your grandfather
because he likes to get high.
Wow.
That's the dumbest Shit I've ever heard.
That's the dumbest use of
serve and protect ever.
But he's fucking crazy that Willie,
he's out there smoke who might
write some more great songs,
be out there playing that guitar
and that was fucking hippies.
But Willie's Auntie,
all other drugs,
the people that work for him,
uh,
there's the saying among
people that work for willy,
if you're wired,
you're fired.
Wow,
that's me.
He doesn't tolerate
any chemicals and shit.
He's,
he's a weed guy.
But those type of like
speed dudes are a nightmare.
Speed people are a nightmare,
right?
Be especially because their,
their sense of judgment gets whacked out.
That's one of the reasons
why they get caught.
They caught this guy who was a lawyer,
it was in Esquire or Gq,
one of those manly men magazines
where it's okay to read it.
And uh,
this dude was a lawyer and then,
uh,
he did something with meth and uh,
maybe it was like based on a
client that he was working with,
taught him how to make math.
And then the guy just was making
buckets of it in his basement.
He just seems like it's,
he was nuts.
And you know,
the cops eventually came over his house
and funnel it was meth and his basement.
They're like,
why was he,
he's acting so crazy.
Like everybody knew
something had to be going on.
Like the guy had zero,
like his,
his ability to make
judgment calls was gone.
So you would never know.
I want to come with her
ass four in the morning.
Things like that.
If you're an old hippie Willie Nelson,
whether your gray ponytail and you sitting
out there and trying to write a song
and you've got this dude working for
you and he's bouncing off the fucking
walls,
climbing trees and shit,
you know,
it's a nightmare.
That would be,
yeah,
that's some Zombie Shit.
Math methods and scary.
Have you ever known anybody,
uh,
older people that had kicked it
and told me that they had done it?
Uh,
no,
it's,
yeah,
that's,
I knew a few people really.
That seems,
that seems nasty.
And then,
yeah,
it's just funny when you travel
around America in the rural areas,
on the side of barns,
there's advertised,
you know like meth destroys
families and lives and like,
and even like above gas pumps,
like you'd drive to the middle of America.
There's just these,
so apparently middle American,
it's just meth.
Crazy.
There's a real problem with rural
areas where there's nothing to do.
Yup.
Let's stay up all night.
I think it's one of those
channels learning language,
play chess.
I think it's,
I think it's one of those
trends you can be doing.
It's really hard to let go.
I think once it gets yet it's Gotcha.
Again,
I need some of their like real
physical detoxification and going,
I need to give you an [inaudible].
Make sure you're not
dehydrated or like he,
you could,
you could get,
your body gets wrecked
cause he just red lining
Ge.
So when you finally get off
of your body's just like,
oh my God,
he just barked it,
cooked it.
You ever met anybody that used to do
like wasn't into math and then started
doing math?
Uh,
no.
I've met a couple of evil and they lose
like a good percentage of their ability
to like be a normal person.
They didn't miss a chunk and they're
always going to be a little wacky,
just a little wacky.
Some dudes get through it fine.
There's a few MMA fighters that had math
problems and then had like real issues
with it and then like almost died and
then became an incredibly disciplined
because they had like been to the edge
and pulling themselves out of that and
then recognizing that they have a problem
and they'd be turning their ass around
beat dragon completely.
So now they resolved and
like never be defeated again.
It's like some of the
toughest guys in the,
in a MMA or like that,
there's a few guys and had
like court McGee who was a,
who won the ultimate fighter.
He had a like real
substance abuse problem.
He was actually brought back.
He was resuscitated.
Wow.
Yeah.
Even when was the last time
you ever heard about that?
From weed due date of pot,
Brownie and died,
you know.
No,
but we it just accept that a certain
amount of penny guy hit a pot brownie and
really enjoyed Spiderman.
Three the best sex ever.
If you haven't fucked on pot
cookies or pot Annabelle's,
you're,
you really don't even
know what sex feels like.
It's,
it's like the same thing between eating
an ice cream Sundae high and eating an
ice cream sundae sober.
Such a completely different experience.
Like completely,
totally different.
But,
but sex and pot cookies
just cranks the whole thing up.
Walk
every,
every sense.
Just firing,
crackle,
Wacko,
cold
and you're freaking out.
Can you believe you're alive?
You're weirded out by
sex in the first place.
Then we make an a baby.
What's going on here?
Wow.
Crackle.
You were a,
um,
a talk show host in Amsterdam
when everything was illegal here,
but everything was legal there.
What the fuck was that like?
I cried myself to sleep every night.
It was terrible.
Jeff,
you know,
Tom and I have been friends for a long
time when we first I knew about you,
but I didn't meet you
until we did a thing.
Um,
in New York when we were
both on TV at the same time.
You had the time roadshow and
I had that news radio thing,
but it was like right away
I can tell you were like,
oh real comic like right.
We had it like a few,
we had a few words back and
forth and back and forth.
I'm like this mother,
this is a real comic.
And then after the show a,
you know,
a couple of years later,
hey here,
Tom Rhodes is doing a fucking talk show
over in Holland in Amsterdam and he's
not even doing it as Tom Rhodes.
He's like playing a
character and we're like,
that sounds like Tom rose.
That sounds like something Tom Rhodes.
We do just fucking out there doing it.
Just out there gangster style.
It was awesome.
And I was like one of the
best experiences in my life.
What was it called again?
Well it was the Kevin Masters
show at first and nobody,
they didn't any magazine
newspaper interview I did.
They would say,
well why is it Kevin
Masters who's Kevin Masters?
And I would always say,
I don't know that they,
um,
they came up with the idea,
we're going to get an American and we're
going to do this like American late
night talk show and we're going
to call him Kevin Masters.
So
did they ask you to stick with that name?
No.
Well no,
because then I never went along with it.
I would never,
whenever anybody would say Kevin,
I would say name is Tom.
I never,
I,
yeah,
I spent my whole career
trying to establish my name.
I'm not gonna fucking,
that's like,
so it was silly.
So then,
uh,
seasons two and three,
it was Kevin Masters starring Tom Rhodes.
Oh,
that's nice.
So at least they gave
me the star or anything,
but it was,
it was,
you know,
once in a lifetime experience,
um,
there would be like for this girl,
this love story,
and I was playing in Europe a lot,
primarily London.
I was flying back and forth to London,
um,
every other weekend and all
the gigs all over Europe.
And,
uh,
it didn't work out with this girl,
but I had fallen in love with Holland
and Europe and I got this amazing
television,
you know,
do you want to stay and,
and post your own show.
And I grew up watching Carson
and Letterman and you know,
to be that guy coming out from behind
the curtain in the $3,000 suit and then
you stand on the x and you get to do
your little five minute monologue.
And then you walked to the desk and
you banter with your musical hosts,
which I had one little hip hop
guy named [inaudible] life.
And then,
you know,
and then you'd do a skit
and then he could be a,
you know,
you do a skit.
And then first guest.
Uh,
and then my favorite part of the show,
every episode I would get to make a five
minute film where I would experience
something of Dutch culture.
Uh,
one day I spent on a Dutch farm with
a farmer and I walked into an electric
fence.
He said,
look out for the electric fence in Dutch,
but I don't speak Dutch.
So you know,
seeing like somebody get electrocuted.
This hilarious.
How,
how does,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's not that bad.
Can I cook a Dick off?
No,
but it makes you jump like a Mofo.
I heard a good luck.
Literally Cook Your Dick off.
So I'm like,
I got it.
I got a tour of the,
you know,
the red light district and the uh,
sex laws were explained to me that I
was given a tour of Gay Amsterdam by the
guy that does the gay parade.
Uh,
I got to cover the,
uh,
the prime minister debates
the lice strikers as bots.
And I was on the floor with a press
badge and a microphone and I'm talking to
their most powerful,
there are most important
political leaders where like,
I couldn't even meet the
governor of my stake.
And then in the United States.
Yeah.
Unless you were lucky you
were standing next to him.
Really cool moments.
You know,
tenacious d came over and I filmed
a great one of the eye that,
that five minute film,
I gave them a tour of
Amsterdam that's on youtube.
I'll be showing tenacious d around.
You know what else on Youtube?
There's a video.
I think it's on live leak.
Actually,
Brian,
tell me if this is real.
These two dudes,
they piss on an electric fence and we
both get electrocuted at the same time.
Have you seen it?
Yeah,
that's totally real.
Pulled out of think.
It's funny watching a dude
walk into an electric fence.
Check out what it looks like when two
dudes past tense at the same time.
That's shit hurts.
So bad touching.
Oh it is is ridiculous.
It's hilarious.
Wow.
I didn't know what would happen.
I wonder.
I wonder if it Dick's are okay.
Probably not right.
I imagine the amount of force
that goes through your cock.
I wouldn't even chance that one.
If it makes your Dick numb forever.
You shouldn't do things that like
tamper with the performance of your,
nope.
That's what I'm talking about.
Don't let us on an electric fence.
Tattoos.
No piercings.
Snowed Jack pillows.
Yeah.
Those dudes that split their Dick.
That's Ooh.
Oh my God.
It looks like one of those hot
dogs he put on a Weber microwave,
microwave the microwave.
I thought he's just explode.
It's when you split them,
you know you split people like,
like hot dogs,
sandwiches.
Like that was more like of
a back east sort of a thing.
You know you'd get okay,
here it is.
Watch this stupid fucks.
They both get out.
Oh,
I go to Paris on something.
Do you just have to go somewhere in Piss?
You ever noticed that when
they piss they don't just,
they don't just like pull their
pants down and piss on the ground.
They have to find something that way.
It's a male thing.
Totally.
Yeah.
This is a military fence too,
so I'm sure pop,
oh,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
That's the only one guy.
There's another one with
see writes in his stream.
Hits the electrical.
That's a faint.
He fell like the tree.
Felling a tree.
Hey Man,
what the fuck makes people faint?
It was having this conversation
the other day with a friend.
What?
What did,
what is it that makes people faint?
Yeah.
Any idea?
The Beatles.
Elvis is what is the mechanism I use?
It's supposed to protect you
from something like what do you,
why does,
why do people think,
um,
well,
goats,
the fainting goats,
I don't know if you know about those
citizens guts where I think is used as a,
uh,
as what you just said,
defense mechanism,
but kind of defense mechanism.
I think it's something to like
maybe blood running too fast too.
You know,
your heart or something like,
you know what I mean?
Like it might be something like that.
It was like if someone was trying to
eat you and you just fall down and play
dead,
that's a terrible strategy.
But what the fuck do I know?
You know why he didn't want to made the
platypus nature where I had to get who?
What guy were you talking
to about fainting with?
Oh,
what was he making you?
A girl that I dated a long time ago
had a real problem with needles,
um,
where she would see her in a
movie and she would just pass out.
And I was like,
I was like trying to figure,
I go to something happened to you.
Like what?
You know,
like what was well,
no,
she apparently when she was young she
had some sort of a really bad infection
and they had to give her a bunch of shots,
like a bunch of shots and apparently it,
it just hurt like hell and
it just traumatized her.
But then she told me that her dad
was a doctor and her dad would faint.
Oh,
her dad,
he was a dentist actually,
but he would faint.
Like he would see his son,
his son had like blisters
on his face because he,
uh,
he was out in the sun.
That sunburn.
He was sunburned,
so bad that he started getting like
these little blisters on his face.
The father saw and just
falls down and passes out.
Like,
wow,
what kind of,
that'd be hard to be a dentist
and not be able to give a shot.
I guess it's,
it has to do with it.
His son
and he couldn't take it
because it was his kid.
And you know,
the love that he has for his boy and he
sees him hurt and damaged the freaks out
and just like this is too much
and just completely checks out.
Hmm.
Um,
I want to give a shout out to my dentist,
Dr Pelerin.
Uh,
the man just retired.
He's been our little family dentist
and are in Florida for years.
Oh,
that's great.
This guy could give a shot.
Oh my God.
Ain't got slay a artist.
Just an artist.
The way it didn't hurt.
And now there's a person who's
replaced him ruthless as good.
Not as good.
It's a Jab,
right?
Yeah.
It's fucking terrible.
Abby,
with that fucking needle.
Gee,
did you see this shit about
these as a storm chasers,
the cotton,
that hurricane or the tornado rather?
I think I saw something
for flash second there.
Those dudes that were on that show,
storm chasers.
Oh,
they killed when they
got killed by a tornado.
Wow.
The,
uh,
let's kind of,
Steve Irwin,
isn't it?
A little bit,
but no,
because what these guys were
doing was measuring the,
the velocity of the wind and how
far it tastes like they were,
they were recording data
that how she to do this.
Yes and no.
I mean I think you have to,
you got to be right up on it now with
his litmus to register like the speed of
the wind and shit like that.
I think like,
it varies in,
you know,
like where are wherever
you are from close to far.
And I think they make those calculations
based on a lot of data that they take
in the field.
As far as I know,
there's a great benefit
to doing it like that.
Wow.
That Oklahoma City,
that was amazing.
I was in New Zealand where
that happened and it just like,
you know,
Eh,
uh,
as the story was unfolding,
it's amazing how,
you know,
news goes around the world instantly,
but you know,
you'd like a mile wide path
ripping through the city.
Just the devastation.
It's any time.
Do you remember Joplin,
Missouri?
Oh yeah.
God,
that one we got wiped out.
It's like literally didn't exist anymore.
Right.
It's,
it's,
and if you look at it,
it was an older town too.
I had passed through.
I used to,
when I did the road,
I drove through Joplin a few times,
like a
brush,
like a mile wide brush,
just just like a big horse hair brush.
Just scrubbed it right
off the face of the world.
It's just,
it's an incredible thing that the wind
in under certain conditions can reach
that kind of a frenzy.
You know?
It's really,
it's,
it's so shocking.
Like our,
our calm world that we live
in for the most part is,
uh,
it's,
it's so different than what happens
with the fucking door dado comes,
it's just so hard for us to
wrap our heads around it.
Fuck.
Tornadoes do,
did you ever see,
do you ever see the one from Dallas
or it's throwing semis in the air?
Semis are spinning around
in a circle like leaves.
Wow.
It's insane.
They're just flying through the air 18
wheelers just flying through the air.
It's throwing around trucks.
It doesn't even drop him.
It's just spinning them around.
It's like a goddamn movie like that,
that twist her movie.
Twister,
twister.
What's her name?
Uh,
at a wet t shirt on the scene.
Helen Hunt.
That was,
that was it.
That's the thing about New
Zealand that I really enjoyed.
They go really,
uh,
there's a nice filter of,
of,
of negative,
of negative news.
They don't,
they don't get in New Zealand.
Um,
they don't like the Middle East
doesn't even exist in their news.
You don't,
you don't hear any stories about Syria,
Israel,
um,
you know,
in the United States it's always shootings
and bombings and disasters in New
Zealand.
The newspaper is like a
sheep gotten the road.
Will you interview,
you know,
very calm.
We do there.
We interviewed them in person.
Yes.
I want to meet that guy.
He's a fascinating guy.
He would love the guy and a,
you should hear it.
You should listen to the
conversation I did with him.
He's really articulate.
Oh,
brilliant.
And the guy's really funny too.
He's,
he's uh,
he's got a great sense of humor.
Um,
it was remarkable.
I did the,
uh,
NPR of New Zealand,
Radio New Zealand.
And the woman asked me,
you know,
what would you like to do
while you're in New Zealand?
And I said,
I'd like to meet kim.com and a few hours
later he followed me back on Twitter
and I looked at his Twitter thing and,
uh,
he had an email and I sent
him a nice email and said,
I'd like to do chat,
which I think is really fascinating guy.
And he's really portrayed in the
American media is a site kind of,
you know,
bond,
villain,
you know,
uh,
bad person.
But I think the guy manipulated the
strengths of the tools he was working with
when the Internet came on.
And he's the reason a lot of
rules were put into place.
He,
you know what,
he totally straightened me out because
I had the misconception that I thought
the website mega upload did,
he made all the money from,
I thought,
oh,
that's like the Napster
of movies or something.
You know,
I'd never used it.
I didn't know what it was.
Um,
and he,
he corrected me.
He said,
no,
they never had a search engine thing.
You couldn't type in
Avatar and find Avatar,
whereas the,
the Napster,
you could stretch search in Metallica
Zeplin and I'd get all this stuff.
So they never had that.
It was people sharing files,
like kind of Dropbox or something,
you know,
and he didn't,
know what was,
uh,
people were,
were,
were trading or sharing it and a,
it,
he's a fascinating guy,
man.
I sent him an email,
he invites me to his mansion and,
uh,
it was on the last day I was there.
So,
uh,
you know,
I was from,
from his house to the airport.
I only got to talk to him for an hour,
but just wonderful man invites
me into his home and just,
you know,
uh,
[inaudible] the guy is,
he's,
I think he's kind of like
an Internet visionary.
He's got a lot of great thoughts about,
um,
where the Internet is going and,
and,
and then,
you know,
in the United States is trying to
extradite him other than really,
yeah.
And it's a charge piracy,
I guess if it's,
he had like the best DVR ever.
Like,
Hey,
do you want to watch like all these
homemade porns from every single person
that's ever uploaded this mega upload,
which is what I was only there an hour.
I didn't,
I didn't get to see the upstairs.
Those aren't going to be good.
They're going to be fat dudes with their
tongue out of their car right in front
of the Lens.
That's what we're going to see
if you tuned into people's,
no,
no.
He's sick.
He's got you guys got a beautiful wife.
He's got like five kids.
He's a Gamer man.
The Guy Loves Games and I
bet you guys great movies,
Huh?
Uh,
I was a fan of his
way back in the day.
He had a really cool website.
He was like one of the first guys that
had like this really like high level
personal website and it was all like,
he had an animated feature
where I think it was Milosevic.
Is it?
Who's the,
the evil guy?
Most of it.
Yeah.
I think it was him that he was,
he was killing in his,
uh,
in his,
our cartoon that he had on his website.
Like if it was like all flash animated,
like really bad ass it called,
I forget strong battery.
It was kim.com even find it.
I don't even know if he was calling
himself Kim Dotcom back then.
I think it was,
he was just calling himself Kim.
Yeah.
But uh,
he,
his website was like genius.
It was like really high level shit.
My friend Andrew turned me
onto it and he was like,
you gotta look at this guy's website.
Like this guy's website
is on another level.
And I went to,
and I was like,
whoa.
Right.
He was on top of the Internet
game from the beginning.
This is like late nineties,
I think.
Maybe.
Yeah,
maybe 2000 at the most.
So it was a fascinating
fucking website back then.
So this guy is like being at the front
line or the Internet for a long ass time.
That was when he was doing like hacker.
He was a hacker and then he went into
security and he was doing like security
for big companies.
That's what he said.
He got busted and then
he got hired by like 18.
His fist story's fascinating.
Right.
You know,
uh,
the only thing I didn't
get to ask him was,
who do you want to play you in the movie?
Um,
they,
he was a hacker from first
and then he got a good call.
Uh,
and then he got hired by at and
t and all these companies to,
for him to explain,
you know,
the workings of their system
and how someone could get in.
I mean,
yeah,
I would imagine you need that
if you're a fucking bank,
right?
Yeah.
A little.
That's what's amazing.
That they allow you to,
yeah.
Bank online,
but you can vote online.
That's,
that's hilarious.
It's a,
it's too dangerous and ensure the
veracity of this transmission to dangerous
voting online folding is too important,
but your money,
this is more convenient.
Hmm.
I can't find anything about
it as early cartoons stuff.
Anyway,
I had a,
I had a great conversation with him for
an hour and he's very generous for him
to do that.
And the guy loves comedy pull
up versus Malosha Vich uh,
I don't even know how to spell that.
And uh,
you know,
I,
I found him very humorous
and a a good dude.
I enjoy looking at him in his eyes and,
and uh,
asking him whatever I felt like.
What do think
the argument is?
Do you think the argument is that people
should be able to share files and then
if you buy something,
you should be able to put online and
other people she will to pull it down if
they want it and upload something that
they bought.
But as long as someone's buying the
original thing and uploading it,
then it's not theft.
That's what a lot of people feel and a
lot of people feel like as long as I'm
not actually taking,
if it was paid for once,
Sherry,
well,
yeah,
I don't know.
I think they,
you know,
they're going to limit it as
much as they possibly can,
but I don't think they'll ever to,
you know,
with Dropbox and all these
different technologies,
it'd be impossible to,
to totally stop it.
Yeah.
But what I'm asking is like,
what is his argument?
Like,
what is it,
you know,
guys and get I give you,
you,
you're my,
I leave you my iPod with my
fucking massive music collection.
You know,
it's supposed to take,
I'm supposed to like say no,
I'm gonna give this back to the RCA.
God roads paid for all these songs.
Well,
I didn't know he liked,
yeah.
Fancy client or whatever.
Man,
I'm fucking rock that Patsy Cline.
But yeah,
like who's the center?
Right.
Which is to say what
happens to it after you,
but I don't,
they'll never be able to control
that for everything being paid for.
What does kim.com,
uh,
argument,
like does he think that
things should be that way?
That you should be able
to [inaudible] you know,
and uh,
this is me speaking,
I think,
you know,
he did.
He's the reason a lot of
rules were put into place.
So,
you know,
and,
and now he's his,
his,
his website.
And when it,
you know,
he's complying with a business.
It's kind of like in New Zealand,
they feel like the guys kind of,
uh,
being persecuted by the
American government.
He thinks like the Hollywood studios
that backed Obama's campaign,
uh,
they're the ones that wanted,
you know,
perpetuate this and have him
extradited and face charges.
And he's,
you know,
and if he is made an
example of then other,
you know,
Internet,
hacker or whatever,
people,
it sends a message to those people,
you know,
that makes sense.
I mean,
they definitely do that with
entertainers that get caught.
We're not paying their taxes.
Like,
like blade,
they put him in jail.
They put Wesley Snipes and
Jeff for three fucking years.
You know,
he was trying to pay it back.
They're like,
yeah,
no,
I mean,
he couldn't even,
they didn't even say,
hey,
you owe us money and
since you lost in court,
now you have to pay it plus a fine.
They're like,
no,
we're going to take your freedom publicly
for three years and lock you in a cage
as you're,
you know,
nearing your early fifties.
It's not going to be so fun.
And then when you get out,
we'd like all that money back please.
Then when you get out,
you've got to claw your way back.
Okay.
And then he's a little aged as an actor.
You know what they would he do that so
long that he's putting on plays in the
jail.
He might lose his chops a little bit.
Staying Sharp,
but you should listen to my,
uh,
my podcast with him.com.
How do I get it?
Is it iTunes?
Tom Rhodes radio,
Tom Rhodes radio.
Why'd you choose that name?
Because I thought I could play whatever
I wanted and I'd take like sound clips
from movies and like,
and when I talked with Comedians,
um,
I'll,
I'll put little snippets of
their standup in there and stuff.
Do you going to run into
problems doing that?
I know and I've tried it.
I don't have any commercials.
It's free.
Hmm.
Okay.
So,
uh,
free.
Uh,
so,
so does that not work ladder.
And that's what I did at the beginning
and that's why I call it tomorrow it's
radio.
But now I don't do
movie clips or anything.
I'll just,
I'll take some stand up.
Um,
you know,
if somebody didn't know,
uh,
Hedberg Hedberg or something,
he comes up in conversation.
Perfect example,
you know,
to do a little sliver of
a couple of his jokes.
So it's just,
I kind of approach it like if I was a,
I'm a university professor
teaching a master class in comedy,
you know,
it's,
it's a lot of Comedians,
but a lot of also interesting people do.
People I admire,
you know,
like I admired Kim Dotcom.
I,
I sent him a message,
I got in touch with them.
Do you edit it all yourself?
Uh,
my wife helps me.
She edits it.
What do you use to put
everything together?
What's the like pro tools?
What do you use?
Oh,
just garageband.
Garageband said it all together.
Great.
Anybody can do,
you can be your own Internet mogul
now you've got the technology.
You don't have to,
that's the video.
This is from,
I mean,
I want to say like it work,
right?
You can't be any later than 2000
used to call himself Kim there.
It was just Kim expert Kim.
I don't know what his actual real name is.
Kim Schmidt,
but this is a him.
He was something like that.
He's like a character.
God.
He makes,
he makes rap songs and dance songs.
That's the mega car that Ma,
how you knew what it was.
Yeah,
I remember this.
I remember this well.
He had a whole thing.
Yeah.
Like the guy gets out,
he gets on a speed boat.
He's just letting you know
he's a bad motherfucker.
He takes his crash car
to leave a faster boat.
Now I'm gone,
bitch,
push.
I'm like James Bond up
in this motherfucker.
So he's a flying around
on the water in his boat
and he presses the eject button.
So this was his,
I guess his obsession
with all things mega.
Yeah.
Look,
any lands on the bottom
of this helicopter.
Then he lands on a building.
Microsoft,
Microsoft
was having sex with the building.
It's sliding down the building,
built.
He's Bill Gates.
He's going to shoot Bill Gates.
What a great idea.
Oh my God.
It guns down.
Bill Gates.
That's brutal
to him.
It says this is,
this is for winners.
Me.
So Bill Gates
peeing on the ground and it turns
out he didn't actually shoot him,
but he shot around him.
The word Linux you lane.
And that's so funny.
That's not the one that I saw.
I saw it.
I'm glad he didn't kill Bill Gates.
Yeah,
I thought he was killing it was
like that was really twisted.
Yeah,
he's,
he does.
These were all long time ago.
This was like,
there was nothing like
that on the Internet.
People weren't doing it
on their own website.
It's really strange.
Right.
Anyway,
yeah.
Do you,
uh,
what do you do your,
um,
you,
you just edit it all yourself and put
it live or put it up on iTunes but you
don't do like a lot Ustream
version or anything like that?
The cloud and uh,
but I'm going to Ustream version,
like the video,
little snippets of video
and put it on Youtube.
I,
my youtube channel is King
of ha ha king of [inaudible]
and a,
it sounds like a middle man help ones.
Uh,
and I,
I didn't,
I didn't film Kim got calm.
I felt so privileged to be in
the guy's house when I got there.
I was enjoying just
meeting the guy so much.
I know.
I actually said,
we don't need to do this,
bro.
I'm just happy to meet you.
Right.
And I actually,
you know,
I was just so glad to be sitting there
and talking to the guy and then he said,
no,
no.
You know,
um,
you know,
please,
if you want to,
if you want to record
the act of doing a podcast
makes conversations happen
that might not necessarily
how,
how like,
like you and I,
okay,
we might go have dinner somewhere,
but I might,
you know,
take a phone call.
You might go to take a leak,
you know,
we're not going to sit down for three
hours and just drink coffee and smoke a
little weed and just talk like this.
Like,
it's almost like you need this vehicle,
uh,
putting on a show to,
to,
to get it out there,
you know?
Yeah.
It's cool.
But my,
my,
my wife also achieved,
she's,
she films a lot.
I've filmed a lot,
so we ain't got great stuff
with Stan hope and um,
Steve,
uh,
yeah.
Um,
they're coming out a little faster now.
I've got a lot of backed up episodes.
What's it man?
It's,
that's the beautiful thing about podcasts.
All you really need,
if you want to do an audio podcast,
especially,
you just need an iPhone and you can do,
I've,
we've done ones where Brian,
what kind of a editing did you have to do?
When I did those podcasts on the plans?
Did you have to do anything to it?
No,
I just cut off that
beginning and end and just,
it's amazing.
And then put commercials on the
sound of the plane wasn't a,
Oh,
it's Kinda cool.
It's Kinda cool.
It's in the background,
you know?
And then,
you know,
like what I do is I'd hold the iPhone
between like me and Joey are me and Dunkin
and me and Ari or Brian.
And did we ever do one Bryan's
never do podcast on the planet.
We should have that like a
regular episode when we do gigs.
Do podcasts on a plane.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
I did it.
I did the Austin Moontower festival.
Was that a comedy festival?
Yeah,
it's great.
It's an Austin.
I just a second year and uh,
I love Ari.
He's awesome.
Oh my God.
Just his face makes me happy.
I enjoy dead guys.
I enjoy his company so much.
And I did it.
I sat down and then it was having a great
conversation with him for my podcast
and then Marin walks out cause we were
on these balconies at the hotel and then
Marin sits down and then it's,
you know,
it comes all about all about marriage,
but there's,
I've got great video.
It did,
it really,
that is really what happened was,
but Marin's great.
And the thing,
cause I was having this great,
I didn't know he had been like Orthodox
and that he had lived in Israel and
stuff.
So I'm like story,
I'm asking him all these things that like,
I just,
I,
you know,
what's the squiggly,
uh,
sideburns mean?
What's the Tassel on the pants thing mean?
What's with the big fuzzy hat?
So that Ari's like Ari's totally knocking
him down and he's totally school me
on,
uh,
all these,
these questions that I had.
And then Marin comes out.
There it is.
Boom.
Did Marin think that he was supposed to
be there or they're just coming to Mary
knew we were recording
the first like 20 minutes.
Oh,
compensation,
front of a laptop and then he's
probably in the groove now.
He's a funny cat man.
He's a,
he's become a different dude.
It's interesting.
It's cool watching a guy
finally drop some of the anger,
like
getting success.
Yeah,
it's great when somebody,
uh,
yeah,
getting into it with people.
He,
Michael,
Ian Black and him were going back and
forth on Twitter or are they doing oh well
my Michael Ian Black was
dominating Marin on Twitter.
Oh really?
Oh,
I don't believe that's right.
I don't care for it.
They've done it before.
Twitter slap downs.
When comedians get all
bitchy with each other,
it seems to be,
I mean,
we're on the word,
the lowest rung on the Showbiz.
Slacker man.
It's like dough lets you know.
How about,
how about a little malware brotherhood
fellows could have easily been fucking
around,
but it just didn't seem like it
told a great story that
I had asked him about it.
It's,
it's a little different
the way he tells it,
but the way I remembered it,
um,
you know,
Marin,
he'd only been doing comedy
for a couple of years.
He moves to la,
he's a doorman at the comedy store.
He's living at the comedy store house
and Kinison is massive at the time.
And Kennison like to come by and
party and everything and Marin's like,
you know,
only been to a comedy
for a couple of years.
And,
um,
he went to pick up a college friend of
his at the airport and he comes back to
the house and he comes in and Kennison
is standing on his bed pissing and Marin
turns to his buddy and he goes,
I told you I knew him.
I heard Ken was a real piece of shit.
He wasn't,
he was a bad dude by the way.
Got To remember this a to say this,
uh,
our IISHA fears new comedy central show,
the online version of it.
Um,
he,
uh,
has a new thing that comedy
central studios is doing online.
It's called this is not happening.
And he just released the first one today.
It's a Tj Miller has a seizure.
I watched it.
It's,
it's brilliant.
Especially the opening part of it.
There's like this,
he has this animated thing,
pull it up Brian.
It's uh,
it's on the comedy central.
A page on youtube,
which is just comedy central.
And um,
it's,
this is not happening.
Tj Miller has a seizure.
This is not happening.
Just see the,
the beginning of the opening,
a animated video,
whoever did it is a bad motherfucker cause
it looks really cool and they decided
to do it.
It looks like they did it in a strip club.
It looks like they did
it in like one of those.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a Cheetah's.
Oh is it cheese or where we're in Atlanta.
I know there's like a Cheetah is here,
but that's where like Sam does a
lot of comedy shows that really,
Oh that's brilliant.
Yeah.
How would those shows those fun?
Great.
Look at this opening in the least
amount of words possible.
You're jumped out as HR.
That was going to happen.
Check this out.
This is the opening animation for
those newer saw three dimensional shits
flowing.
The air is really cool.
Welcome to,
this is not happening.
Present crazy nights over a
bunch of comedians tell stories.
Similar subject.
So this,
this is an idea
Ari had a,
that he came up with a long ass time ago,
I think as like a writing exercise.
I mean I think that was his idea.
Just to have a different kind of show
where you instead of just do like
hardcore,
like set up punchline,
you know,
created bits.
He wanted people just tell wacky stories.
Like the one time that like Bert Kreischer
has a fucking story but getting so
drunk that he's over his girlfriend's
father's house and he's the guy walks down
into the living room while he's
pissing on the dining room table.
Like standing there with his dick
out on the dining room table pissing.
Hmm.
We've all had a little too much to drink.
Yeah.
That's,
that's some next level shit already.
Storyteller nights at the
Austin Moontower festival.
He did,
uh,
drug story.
Yeah,
I told that.
Um,
Dalai Lama tail.
That's a great story.
Yeah.
Those are these things that already does.
They're,
they're really fun.
I love that.
And it really interesting.
But sometimes people cheat.
I've talked to already about just
going to Israel and doing shows and um,
and I just talked to Moshe Kasher.
He had played this club that I
wanted to look into and he said,
you have to be squeaky clean.
What would be the fun of that?
What kind of world that you live in it,
it's just we've all got handle,
you know,
fucking religious tension
and fucking suicide bombers,
but they can't handle a little dick.
Yup.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
That's absolutely preposterous.
That actually hurts my feelings.
It does.
It's going to be clean.
Why?
What do you do?
Are you going to live forever
if you don't say fuck,
what are you doing that you
would need to join this more?
If everything's fucking
sanitized and like what?
Like all due respect.
What keeps a guy like
Seinfeld doing stand up?
Do you know anything about him?
No,
I don't.
I know what kind of cereal he likes.
He likes Porsche's.
Let me know.
He likes portion.
Yes.
It's like he's got like a hundred cars,
some crazy Porsche fetish,
you know,
drives a lot of old ones and shit.
Man.
I know he's a great comic and you know,
he's a great joke writer
who's got great delivery,
but he's got that one
observational one layer style.
Like there's no side
when I have children at won't
allow them to watch him.
I would never want my kids to,
I relate that kind of comment,
but
look it online,
pornography,
kids,
whatever you want.
You watch them.
Old Carland tapes.
No Seinfeld in this house.
Where does that other,
I had to go to this store.
I go to the grocery store.
I'm just picking up a couple of things.
Jerry goes,
go to the store jokes.
It's an air who cheese?
I just run down to the milk
because they know each other.
Oh,
I know.
We were both milk and I love you.
You've grown up your cheese,
you know,
every,
all bilk starts off
cheese starts off as milk.
When she sees milk,
does it remember it's old friends.
Look at you.
You moved.
I should clarify.
He,
uh,
I met him once and I didn't care for him.
I thought he was,
you know what happened?
It was at the comedy cellar.
It was 98,
99.
I was living there.
And um,
I,
you know,
the seller,
everybody goes to the seller,
you know,
at the end of the night.
And I had a sat there and I get that,
you know,
it's,
it's a small club.
There's a table in the
back where Comedians,
um,
go on or before they go on.
And I get there and every,
all the comedians are in the hallway.
Nobody's at the table and the,
Oh,
Jerry's here.
And so I go back,
I'm on next,
I sit down and give
them a little head nod.
Hey,
I liked the guy who up to that time,
I could see him while I was on,
I did 20 minutes and a,
I had a great set.
I know that.
And then the next night he's at the,
uh,
they had the Mediterranean restaurant
upstairs and I get there early to do my
set.
And,
um,
I see Collin Quinn at the bar,
he's a buddy of mine.
And I go over to,
Hey Collin,
how are ya?
And he goes,
Hey,
you know,
Jerry and Jerry sit in there honker and
over a plate of chicken wings and he's
holding a chicken wing and
he looks me up and down.
And he goes,
isn't that the same sport
coat you had on yesterday?
And I go,
I only had one season on NBC.
Jerry,
you might be able to afford a different
jacket every night of the week,
but I only had one season.
And he just like shrugged and he went
back through his chicken wings and it's
like,
you know,
a guy with that much money
to like seriously look
someone up and down and like
criticized their clothing.
There was guys in my high school
that thought they were funny.
That's all they did.
It criticized peoples.
You know,
some people don't have money.
I see some people having a tough time,
hey,
I'm sorry.
You know,
we didn't get the fucking
wash the clothes or whatever,
you know.
Uh,
but I always thought it was really
cheap when people like just pick apart
someone's appearance.
That's not comedy.
That's like being a bully.
What do you know?
Yeah.
And it had only works if you're not aware
of the impact that it has on another
person.
Because as soon as you are aware of the
impact that has on the other person and
you do it anyway,
you know like non instigated,
you start off like picking
on a guy's wardrobe,
you're a Douche bag like this.
There's no,
but in his defense that is a style of
like comedy interaction in New York.
Everybody criticizes everybody and that
they do it all the time and maybe he
just wanted you like to know
that you were like welcome.
Wow.
And I took it the wrong way.
Sorry Jerry.
This is possible.
I mean that's some chicken
never heard of the guy being no,
no.
I you see him interviewed
a thousand times.
You'd get an idea like Alec Baldwin
going to have to start watching that show
and then see Alec Baldwin
yelling at you for something.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like Alec Baldwin seems
like he's a fucking hothead.
It tightly wound.
But Jerry Seinfeld,
could you ever see Jerry Seinfeld
screaming at a flight attendant?
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
I just don't think he's a Dick.
I don't think he's got it.
He might make a snide
comment here and again,
but so you go back,
we did all routes.
A few off.
I'll let my kids watch him.
I love Seinfeld.
I liked the show.
I think he's his book.
It's good.
I don't get the end up.
I think his book is just as act.
Yeah,
I think you translate
that to think in comedy.
It's like always,
you know,
when I talked to stand up and stand up,
did my thing,
uh,
who was it?
Somebody like David Cross
was rude to everyone.
So he told me stories like
you can always remember,
you always remember like who was it?
Dig Tia and comedy when
you were coming up.
Yeah,
I forgot that cross
story that he tells that.
So fucking rough story.
It's a rough story and it was,
you know,
you know guys can get Douchey
if you guys can get Douchey,
but they didn't.
That's the thing.
You walk around as a comedian and you say,
oh,
we're all like,
you know,
brothers.
No,
not everybody looks at it that way.
Most of us do though.
TheW and the ones that do are the ones
that you enjoy hanging out with the
really self obsessed crazy ones that
aren't about the camaraderie of stand up.
Those are the ones that wind up kicking
themselves in the Dick or stepping on
their own foot.
You know there's,
there's the silly ones there.
They would have dummies like you,
you wouldn't be any less funny if you
just weren't an asshole to your fellow
comics.
It wouldn't make any less funny.
Didn't buy the open letter
to Larry the cable guy.
Okay.
It wouldn't make you less funny.
It's not like you know
you're going gangster,
but calling out Larry the cable guy.
Dan Whitney is a very nice guy.
He's a very nice guy and I
started out with him in Florida.
Great Guy.
There's a lot of other fucked up shit
out there in the world that you should
probably be concentrating on before you
concentrate on the Larry the cable guy.
Yes.
It's just right where he's a nice fucking
guy and he has delicious potato chips.
Really?
Brian telephones even more now.
I heard that he has,
not only does he have like
a delicious potato chips,
he has like delicious food,
like hamburger helper type shit.
Oh really?
He's coming down with,
it owns food products.
Cable Guy Larry,
the cable guy has a
cheeseburger potato chip.
It tastes like cheeseburgers.
Exactly.
Like cheeseburgers.
Like with mustard on it.
Relish.
It's fucking delicious.
And why you're eating it.
You're like,
I'm going to eat one more and that's it.
Because I think,
I don't know.
What the fuck is it?
I don't know what kind of Voodoo they're
doing on me that a potato chip tastes
like.
I just hated it in and out.
It's very strange.
Not In and out,
but definitely Wendy's.
It's fucking delicious.
It's really good.
It's like you're,
you're eating a potato chip that
tastes just like eating a cheeseburger.
It's so weird,
but it's,
God,
I can't be a smart move.
So hungry now.
Oh,
I got you with the fucking Larry,
the cable guy.
Potato chips.
But I think
David Cross is just a,
he's just a volatile artists.
There were the same thing
that makes them great.
Right.
I know David,
he's always been nice to me.
I mean it's always see,
depends on,
you know,
who you,
who,
who personal your experience with personal
people that you meet and deal with.
You know,
Dave's never been anything.
I've heard some people,
I've met them,
they were the nicest people in the world.
And vice versa.
David's cool to me.
Even after I did fear factor,
which,
you know,
if anybody was like taking
the high brow approach,
that'd be the time to think I was a loser
serving people animal decks and then
I,
you know,
just show us the classic,
what's classic for me.
I told you the last time
I was on the shot that,
that uh,
the magazine industry in this
country collapsed joke went down.
Well,
I'm one of the few people on Earth.
They could say I lost the job
because people had a drink cop.
It's not a lot of people that,
you know,
not a lot of people that can say that,
why'd you lose your last job?
Uh,
we were making people drink calm.
Maca wasn't buying it.
Check this out,
Larry the cable guy at
dinner and get her done.
You want a body like mine?
Look at the reviews
I ever boughten.
Oh,
back it up.
The first one,
Star.
What does the purse,
I says,
Oh,
does anybody remember Larry's
previous was on your recipe?
I can't recommend anyone
buying this product.
Ever Sing,
seen his calm to retune a
comedy routine on Poop Lasagna.
Maybe they just were David Cross fans.
He's got a lot of,
she's got Mac and cheese.
It's got chicken batter.
He did have a joke.
Hilarious
chicken.
Oh my God.
How many stars does that have?
Got Five stars,
five stars.
You know,
you start feeling good about
yourself in this business thing.
Can you,
you've,
you know?
Yeah.
This guy's got this guy,
he's got a private jet because
he was selling Lasagna,
fish batter,
fish batter.
Jesus Christ.
What's crazy is they
think he's like that guy.
It's like,
you know Andrew dice clay who
I'm a huge fan of when he,
the dice man was one of his many
characters that he would do,
but it was so good that he's like
fuck all these other characters.
I'm just sticking with
the salt dice man thing.
And then he became the dice man.
Now he's always the dice Matt.
He's,
but they've morphed and it's not like
he's pretending to be the dice man.
That literally is who he is now.
So when he shows up with
giant sunglasses on that like,
you know like literally six inches
high and he's got a fanny pack made a
leather,
which by the way,
I've got a great fanny
pack because of him.
The route of people that are
looking for a good fanny pack,
a solid one.
The leather roots fanny pack.
That's the one that
Andrew dice clay wares.
But he's done.
He's a nice man that he sent in
his fanny pack money cause Canada.
What's that fanny pack line?
Camp Roots.
Canadian is a Canadian.
Yeah.
Well,
if Americans just had the balls to produce
a quality fanny back and not be those
weird vendors that you know,
a fun and stuff on Amazon,
you're like,
man,
do I send them my fan?
He's like,
what they call the silly vagina.
They're still driving
in the left hand side.
They can't be,
you know,
you lose all your credibility
when you're trying to
cars so that you could use a sword.
I heard that the reason they
do that is because Napoleon,
the conquering armies
getting back to Paris,
they chose the right side.
So the left side is the
loser side of the road.
I think it's actually,
I don't know.
That might just be some weird.
Both guys dude told me at a bar that
wouldn't make any sense because then both
guys be the loser because they're both
on the left depending on which direction
your head again.
But back to Paris.
Oh,
back to Paris.
Um,
here's the,
the thing,
the one that makes sense to me is
that if you're on the left hand side,
you can defend yourself with your right,
which is your,
your strong arm.
Most people are dominant right handed
and they would be holding the sword.
So that's why they would
pass on the left hand side.
And since these are all like ancient
cultures were talking about like England
and mean,
they're really ancient.
I mean,
you think about how long,
you can go to a bar in
England that's 900 years old.
I love that.
It's amazing.
There's a bar in not numb.
It's underneath the castle.
It's on the backside.
Uh,
and it's where people would drink
before they went off on to fight in the
Crusades and shit.
It's amazing.
It's insane.
My God.
Yeah,
that kind of like that kind of history.
It's um,
you know,
it makes sense that they still have
that left side of the road thing.
That's what they did for
fucking hundreds a year.
That makes sense.
Then you could use,
you're right.
You're right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well then I guess that's
the better side of that.
Like if you're jousting,
I think,
you know,
that's how you do it.
Only you would think
of something like that.
No,
it's not that only I'd so I asked,
you know,
oh,
it didn't make any sense.
I was like,
this seems like every we American be.
I asked somebody and they told
me that Bullshit Napoleon,
you know,
well we've made the first cars so it
would make sense that since we decided to
driving the right,
everybody would just honor that Dell like,
yeah,
not feeling it loud.
I'm going to put the stint
in wheel on the other side.
I feel a little more comfortable
like in Sword Swipe out the window.
So they decided even though they wouldn't
have to import our automobile because
we're,
the one's smart enough
to figure it out first.
They still had to put it on the left side.
That's you know,
that's also just not one to bow down to
American dominance and I was wearing,
boy,
a lot of them Europeans still got a
lot of shitty idea is a friend of mine,
this Guy Kevin Healy
who runs the Roshan Dub,
just cool rock club and Galway
Ireland and they do comedy there.
It sounds amazing.
Wonderful Dude.
I Love Golf.
What's the name again?
It's called the in dub.
It's a,
it's like fucking Celtic for black rose.
I need to get a tee shirt.
Can I buy one online?
But yeah,
of course.
Yeah,
totally.
So,
but he's,
he's funny man and he's
a really funny dude.
And his talking gps in his car
is a British woman's voice.
And so I was driving around with
him one and then like it was it,
uh,
take the third into the roundabout and
take the third left and then like he'd
drive it,
you pass it.
And they did go a different way
and he'd just look at me and go,
I need to word that in English,
but it's still doing,
Brian had a girl that he was daddy at
one point in time who did not like that
his navigation system had a girl's voice
because I would like choose like the
British chick voice cause that I thought
that was the sexiest one bed it,
you know,
whatever.
And she was like,
will you please change this?
Why do we have to listen to her?
And like every time I
would come in my car,
she would like have changed.
Jackson's,
that's what's called a
healthy relationship.
Oh right.
Imagine that.
Try bringing that up to a psychologist.
I,
you know,
he tries to make me jealous
with the navigation system.
It's a girl's voice and
the girls are whore.
Okay.
And I remember I,
there was like,
it was from Tom,
Tom and I forget who it was.
There was some kind of
like sexy person that,
that uh,
that they ended up
having these voice packs.
You could buy like Darth Vader
and then it was like a Bob Dylan.
Right.
And there was a sexy one
that I bought and it just,
yeah,
like blew the lid off or wait a minute.
Yeah,
that's how it was.
Do you want to really make some money?
Make a plugin with Joey,
Joey Diaz telling you what a gold,
what the fuck did I just locked up?
Fuck did I just say left our dog,
Chile.
That would be the greatest
navigation system of all time.
We got to find investors.
No one's done it.
My friend David Herwoods did
come up with an idea once,
but it was an idea of Joey
giving advice on the toilet.
Like little,
little short blurbs had to film it.
Yeah.
And he could put,
they called it a fat man on the toilet,
which is disrespectful,
you know,
you've got to coach Joey
Coco Diaz on a toilet.
That's what you want a fat man.
It's not just cause he's fat,
you know,
that was a little on
the spot and he's tall.
He's tall man on the toilet,
you know,
just describe them.
That was a low point in my life,
Joe,
being in that small bathroom and summer
day with a Joey Diaz naked right in
front of me.
The balls hanging over
the toilet seat somehow.
I don't even know how that's possible.
Did you smell him at all?
Oh yeah.
It smelled like a big Joey Diaz.
Like,
I mean it smelled like balls in there.
Yeah.
And then like his wife,
uh,
the person's house.
It's what?
Like the wife would come in with
lemonade and just eliminate anyone,
like real nice.
And I'm like,
don't you see his guys balls is right.
Like this is so creepy.
I felt like I was in Cape Horn.
I thought that was,
I thought that was a hidden
camera joke on me at the time,
Joe,
because I was like,
how am I in right now
is a joke.
It was funny.
I mean it was a Joey's
funny in anything he does,
man.
Joey's was always funny.
Hey,
did you see this?
A transgender navy seal?
Yeah,
count came out.
Yeah.
I used to be a dude is barely look in
Evan Tanner looking dude with a big full
beard and uh,
got a sex change and
became a woman and uh,
now calls herself warrior
princess and just like
went for a full sex change.
I mean she,
she was at one point in time,
20 years as a navy seal,
fought some of the most dangerous
battlefields in the world.
After she left service,
she realized she wasn't living in La.
She wanted,
I decided to become a woman
to go from like that Quito,
a ferocious fighting.
This is off the sensitivity.
That's either you got
to applaud that person.
Yeah.
If that's what you want to do for sure.
It's uh,
you know,
and um,
I put it online and like some people like,
um,
still think there was,
there's an issue with a
transgender MMA fighter.
Uh,
there was a man who became a woman and
then started fighting as a woman and MMA
fights and like just brutally
knocking these women out.
Do you remember that?
That in,
in a,
in the Thai boxing and then in the 90s,
that was the opposite.
There was a guy and then with
his monies cause winnings,
he got the operations
further as he went along.
So he was really good and bad,
a sex change.
And then he didn't have
any testosterone anymore.
He started getting
beaten up by girls can't,
well this a transgender you formerly male,
a woman can and she's
knocked out three girls.
Then she choked out
another girl that recently.
But there's,
there's certain mechanical advantages
to the human body when it's man,
when it's born with a y chromosome.
The testosterone were 30 years of
his life before he became a woman.
And I think that like there's,
that's undeniable.
There's also an advantage
in reaction time,
like what?
It's 10% across the board advantage
and reaction time for men over women.
And like several tests.
It's not like a one time thing where
they got a bunch of slow checks.
Like there's something about the,
the just the male constitution that
makes it more better adapted to certain
physical things.
And fighting is one of them.
And there's some people be,
it became like this gender issue.
And one of the things I found out this is,
it's really fascinating.
There's a rift in the feminist community
and there's feminists that hate
transgenders or should I say don't
approve of transgenders being considered a
woman.
They think a woman is a woman.
And when a man starts off life as a man,
he stays a man.
And you know the thing,
the idea that that woman,
that man is now a woman and can compete
with women in athletics is ridiculous.
And so one of the things they site is
this MMA thing where this check is like
I'm seeing,
I'm not particularly talented,
but she's just a man like bitches
need him in the face and knocking them
unconscious and putting them on the ground
and putting her her knee on people's
necks and choking them out quick.
And it's like she's not fighting like
the elite of the elite competition.
But the way she's winning
is quite convincing and that
sort of stirs the debate
up.
But I've never been in any way,
shape or form against anyone
who wants to be a transgender.
My position is only as
a martial arts expert.
I've been doing martial arts since I
was a child and I know that there are
certain things that make
someone physically more
dangerous and one of them is
bone structure.
It doesn't change when you
have big giant man hands,
big giant man hands of dangerous
as fuck and little tiny hands.
No matter how good you get it,
hitting things,
they never really that dangerous.
A little tiny hands break in
your face like a woman's hand.
They're not.
They're not built for punching shit.
You gotta wrap 'em up
good and put them in pads.
Otherwise I'd just
shatter on your forehead.
There's a lot of things
to to to being a man,
like the way the hips are built.
They,
there's a mechanical advantage
to using the hips that way,
but that doesn't mean I'm
against people being transgender.
I think you should be able to do whatever
the fuck you want and I think that
there's going to be a lot of people when
they do some sort of a chromosome will
switch when they,
they really get into high level genetic
manipulation and they literally can turn
you into a woman.
I think every man should be forced to be
a woman for at least a couple of months
of his life just so you could feel
what it feels like to be vulnerable.
It feels that it feels like
to be Douche on by guys.
I mean maybe if like,
you know how you have to like you,
you live in Israel and you have to
like do like a couple of years in the
service.
I think every man should have to be forced
to live a couple of years as a woman.
Really as a real woman,
like,
Yo,
you're a 250 pound man.
No,
you're a 90 pound Chinese girl now and
this is how you gotta live your life for
the next two years,
two years as a woman.
So you have like real empathy,
but it feels like to be overpowered or
threatened by the opposite sex or the
people who were like sexually attracted
to you also being the most likely ones
to take your life.
You know,
I think when that happens,
it would be a very strange
world when you can just say,
Tom,
what do you this week?
Oh Dude,
I'm a black guy.
And
Oh my God,
Brian would be girls put together
a funk band immediately if you get,
if Brian can be anything
super woman,
super woman or wonder woman,
super woman wonder woman
had more cool shit though.
She had a chat and she had,
but I guess superwoman
can fly in her own right,
cool,
cool places and masturbate.
But yet she never achieved the fame.
That wonder woman had.
It's like what separates Whitney
Cummings from Eliza swessinger?
What is it that makes Whitney
Cummings so much more successful?
That's like wonder woman over superwoman.
I mean maybe Supergirl or
whatever the fuck she was.
Maybe she was really bad ass,
but she never got nearly the props.
That wonder what my guy
wonder woman with her jet.
Do you remember the Dave Chappelle joke
he used to do about that she had an
invisible jet?
No.
What did he say?
What's that prostitute?
They look like
the most ridiculous outfit.
If you could be,
if I could be any superhero
know if between super woman
or why do I say I would
rather that Carter,
I remember Linda Carter,
super woman was blonde hair,
so she wouldn't have to
shave as much like her legs,
like you know,
Brown hair,
you'd have to shave more.
So I think it was less mace
maintenance to be superwoman.
I think you're right.
And I think that wonder woman
can't even fly on her own.
She needs a plan and that just stupid.
Plus she's got her magic
of truth and she's right.
And then the bullet proof,
a wrist band.
Since she's fucking Ka Ching Ching.
And you can move that fast to hit
bullets with your wrists please.
I can't remember like captain slow all
the other times he didn't fly either.
Yeah.
Like yeah,
he was,
he just had a sword.
Well Captain America was
like the ultimate roid man.
Like they created him with like a roid.
It's like a Super Roy,
like they shot off,
he's a little skinny guy in the movie.
Is the movie the same as the comic book?
I never even bothered to watch that piece.
It wasn't really a captain [inaudible]
even though it was a marvel comic.
I mean that was in my wheelhouse,
but I was never really
a captain America guy.
But the movie's not bad.
Well I remember Captain America and I
know when I was a kid in the 70s eighties
looking through,
he would be getting his ass
beat and then his black friend,
the Falcon would show up.
It was always
captain America is getting his ass beat
and then his black friend and it was
like,
you know,
like the mid seventies where like,
they're trying to like integrate
like a black superhero,
but they didn't want to
give him his own magazine.
So then the Falcon would come in and
save the day and kick everybody's ass.
You don't remember the time I do now
that you brought it up or I remember very
much.
That's hilarious.
So,
uh,
dude who played them?
Um,
uh,
did,
they didn't have the falcon the
do to play to captain America.
It was perfect.
Did you see the Avengers?
That dude,
it looks like Captain America.
He's the perfect guy.
He's perfect.
I just don't like the character at all,
so I don't even bother,
you know,
the movie is pretty good dude.
Give it a shot.
I seen the first,
no,
no.
There's captain America.
Really Captain America.
Why is it just because you hate
patriotism and you hate America?
I think that's it.
No.
Is it really,
you hate like Rah Rah old,
the old,
the old captain America
with his little flags.
And stuff like that.
I was,
I was like,
get outta here.
Built such a nice success off.
Nah,
I don't hate the country.
I did just,
his costume was dumb.
Has
I know what you're talking about.
You don't want it,
you know,
this is the rob,
rob,
rob bullshit.
Well,
you know,
just giving him some better superpowers
when they conceived that he was crazy
though.
When in the fifties during world or two
or are we supposed to be
fighting against the Nazis?
Like it's okay to be like Super Patriot
guy when you're fighting against a
legitimate evil army.
You know?
I mean,
that was like a legitimate evil army.
But then once the United States
army becomes legitimately evil,
then captain America becomes a goofy
character and that that's the problem.
It's like,
it's really hard to,
when you look at foreign
policy and drone attacks,
and it's really hard to think that those
fucking people that are pulling off
what they're pulling off,
wherever the fuck we are,
you know,
whether it's the invasion of Iraq or
any of the crazy shit they're doing,
they have fact that the
idea that a noble man,
like Captain America would be
rushing to very to save the day,
making sure the rest of the world
has oil for centuries to come.
Just dodging bullets.
Flying a kickass.
Yeah.
Not the best one.
He's not the best.
The hawks,
the bass,
clearly
like they do.
It's a lot of comics.
I tried to get into like daredevil.
I tried so hard to get in the dairy that,
but having a blind guy,
just not that sexy and that's all yours.
You're just blind to because
he's blind and you look to move.
Good.
Had over like better sense.
Come on.
So there shit,
I don't know and I can't remember any
more than that to get me to buy a fucking
comic book.
God dammit.
Silver surfer is the wall.
The biggest one.
I always wanted to like love.
It never really did it for
me like I tried so much,
but that's such a cool idea
for a superhero like I got,
I didn't get,
I try,
I mean I bought them and
I just never got into it.
Why?
Your man was really hard for like,
I thought the stories were great.
All that Spiderman's Peter Parker web,
all the geos.
You mean the movie silver surfer,
but did you buy the common notes?
Comic books?
I'm talking about common core.
I feel the same way.
Like when I got silver surfer comic books,
I would be like,
Ooh,
a new silver surfers out,
check it out and then I'd be like Yam,
blah blah.
Whereas like Spiderman was always legit.
Yeah.
Spiderman always had x
men always best storylines
ever.
I mean they had some epic
storylines with Phoenix,
you know what I mean?
That was a,
that was a great,
great comic book era.
That was,
that was the real shit man,
you know,
to Dorks,
Dorks,
how many people listening,
right?
Like dorks.
That was one of the saddest things I
had to do when I was starving to death.
I was telling my comic book
collection needed the money,
man.
I had nothing and that's all I had left
some comic books that I accumulated
over,
you know,
10 years of life out there in the world.
I've been read downloading a lot
lately on using like the Marvel App.
You can just sit there and be like,
I want every episode of Hawk.
Oh you don't?
Okay.
Comic books like physical
comic books are bad ass,
but the best experience is on an iPad.
Get that marvel app on the IPAD
and they go frame to frame.
Yup.
Then you don't see what's next and then
you know like you never see a comic book
where you see,
you know,
you always see every page and
you see it right in front of you.
As you're changing the page,
you see the left page to the right page,
see what's coming with these apps.
He just goes and goes frame to the frame
and assumes that in real quick,
kind of like a movie.
Did you ever think that you'd be like
pushing fucking 40 and still talking about
comic books?
Yeah.
You never appeared anticipated
a period of a golfing,
no joke.
I posted a uh,
a test the other day.
I don't know if you saw this,
this is a friend of mine told me to take
it and it's something that I guess a
lot of people take in college and I,
it's like 50 questions and I
ended up taking it and wow.
How crazy.
Like horoscope wise,
like how crazy accurate it is.
And,
and if you just read a what,
see what it's called,
if I can find it real quick,
um,
if you,
if you do it,
I'm really wondering what it is,
but I asked what everybody
else was and they were all the same.
Like they almost every
single person wrote back.
Like I took the test,
I am a I n t,
s,
p,
whatever it was.
And that's like the smallest percentage
of people in the world is this group of
people that all are
following me on Twitter.
So it was really weird.
Here's the test that you can go to.
What is the,
um,
the distinguishing factor that makes
them like a really small group?
I don't know.
It's just like,
you see good.
I'm e s F P and I guess the test is
based on some kind of old school.
Well,
let me try to find it.
It's called the Junge elaborate
way for you to plug your Twitter,
the typology tests.
Did you ever take Carl Young?
Carl Young.
And so I took this and you can go to
like human metrics.com and it's around
there,
but I took this test and just look
at this like description of me.
Uh,
it's uh,
extroverted sensing.
What does it say was extroverted sensing,
feeling perceiving.
And see what it does is it tells you like,
here's all the different
ones that you can be.
And it tells you go down,
uh,
like SFPs love to talk
to people about people.
Some of the most colorful of
story tellers are ESF piece.
Like,
like you go through this thing and
then you can even get more accurate.
And they have like these
horoscopes that are really like,
Whoa,
that's intense.
That's a fascinating,
you know what the problem with these
things as though the problem with these
tests is that you know,
you're taking a test.
Yeah.
Oh,
here's another thing.
That famous Esu would
give them the answer,
the simulation theory.
Bob Hope.
That's hilarious.
Well,
it's just,
you know what it is you,
you,
when you know you're taking a test,
you might not necessarily reveal the
way you would respond to something,
uh,
a regular basis had you
not been measuring it.
But the questions are
pretty basic questions.
Like if you go like,
like you know how to put every
minute of your time to good purpose.
No,
I definitely did not know how to do that.
You know,
so it's,
you know,
or you're a person somewhat reserved
and distance and communication,
I would say.
Yeah.
Besides podcasts,
you know,
it's just,
yes and no.
It's not.
The actions are frequently
influenced by emotions.
Yes,
definitely.
You usually plan your actions and events.
Those are things that you could decide.
What's your thinking with a group
of people attending parties shot.
Yes.
You could decide.
They seem pretty like nonjudgmental,
which is I think important.
If you're going to really have something
like that and have it be accurate.
But I would imagine that would be very
hard to like get a sense of someone's
personality like that.
Try it out.
I would really try to stay cause I,
I've read it and it blew my mind.
I was like no fucking way cause
I've been getting attention.
I know what drives me nuts,
man.
When someone tells me they talked to a
psychic and the psychic knew everything
about me.
Man,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
Dude,
I'm telling you man.
The psychic dude,
he knew he knew about my grandma.
Okay.
And you're like,
oh yeah,
we need a name that begins with as a grit.
She a woman.
Would you say you were from Boston?
She's from the east coast.
I would,
you know,
I just know since your
grandmother was on the East Coast,
um,
what is your father alive?
No,
he wasn't.
I didn't think he was.
No,
no.
Yes,
he was alive.
that's right.
He was alive.
Your father was a lot of,
I see that.
It's amazing.
You see so much?
Yeah,
we'll have a gift of sight
and these cards helped me.
These cards.
It's random cards with drawings on them.
They help me to help me.
See what's hilarious is that no
one ever finds out any new shit.
They just tell you shit.
You already know you fuck.
Like you know dude,
he,
he knew all about my grandmother.
Don't you know all about your grandmother?
Jesus Christ son.
Why?
Why did you go somewhere to
tell you that green is green?
See that color green?
There's no better.
There's no better forecast for the future.
Then a Chinese fortune cookies.
I've based my life up.
I had one a couple of months ago.
It said you are going to
come into a lot of money.
So I took it to the bank.
I was like,
can I get an advance?
Why
Catskills choke?
How about the people that take them and
they the really good ones they save in
their wallet.
Show you guys,
your fucking dog may trust me.
Like modern ones.
There's different,
uh,
well why would they make new ones?
Just keep those fucking dumbass like
all the lottery throw this horoscope.
Who Cares?
People are always going
to eat Chinese food.
It's delicious.
Throw that stupid shit in there.
Some of them,
they are not,
you know,
unfortunate dented in San Francisco
and like 1902 makes sense.
I went to China.
I was like,
man,
where's my fortune cookie?
You don't,
you don't get cookies.
They never carried it over.
Well that's,
you know,
Chinese aren't really innovators.
You know,
they are they the copy.
I would think that they would make
it better Chinese fortune cookie.
The Bullock look,
you know,
you guys,
you had it down
but hologram it doesn't.
Yeah,
it's not dead.
Father should,
it should make a noise.
They always make the cheap shit like
the cheap knock offers and it's like
they're never making like the iPhone.
They're always making like the iPhone
or will they actually make I iPhones
there?
Yeah.
I mean it's shine is
that massive industry.
A lot of Shit in China.
The iPhone factory,
they got the nets around it because all
these people were committing suicide.
Yeah.
Their answer was a,
Hey,
get back to work.
That's based on the apple specs I'm
talking about like all the other company
outs there,
companies out there,
you know,
there's definitely a lot of that.
There's a lot of cheap shit.
You mean made in China was
always like a statement,
right?
Where else are you going to get
refrigerator magnets and snow?
And I looked at it and it said,
made in shine a black,
but they also make some
fucking pretty dope shit.
What's really funny is that,
that uh,
that company,
the,
uh,
where people were jumping off the roof,
what was it called again?
Foxconn.
The argument was this,
I actually saw a guy saying this.
He was saying,
well,
you have to realize that this is an
enormous company and the percentage of
people that are committing suicide is
with the percentage of people in a normal
population of that many.
You're talking about a company that
employs a half a million people.
Yeah.
But the killing themselves at work,
right at work,
the live at work,
they're killing.
I mean,
is it,
are you really,
can you really say that they're
like a regular population,
extra pee break and they just get nothing.
They get very little money
and they claw and scratch.
Just the fact that we still allow that
someone's kind of come up with something
called the fair phone.
Have you heard of that?
Pull it up?
Yeah,
it's a phone they're trying to do.
It's a to you son of a bitch.
It's a,
it's a,
an android phone.
And um,
I think the idea is that they can trace
the origins of all the resources that
are in the phone,
minerals and such and show you that it's
all been acquired to fair trade and it
hasn't been a slave labor used.
And you know,
that seems like a boring phone.
Well,
they can't,
it's not even going to have four G,
which is,
I mean,
it looks like a regular android phone.
What is their,
uh,
their,
their spiel?
She didn't say products and made by
starting with a single phone together,
we're opening up the supply chain and
redefining the economy one step at a time.
I love the idea.
I think the idea is amazing,
you know,
but you got to have four g stupid.
How dare you,
how dare you put out a phone
in 2000 and fucking 13 and say,
well for Lte was problematic,
then your fucking phone is
problematic because I would jump on,
everybody would jump on.
You can do it,
man.
Just make it four g silly.
Get the funding gap.
Get a Kickstarter like Graham Hancock.
He has another Kickstarter.
Alex Grey,
sorry.
Sorry Graham.
Alex Grey's Kickstarter hit $250,000.
So that ends the on thing that he's,
you know,
Alex,
no,
Alex Graves,
the visionary artists.
It was really psychedelic,
crazy trip to mean art.
You never seen his stuff.
Oh,
it was amazing.
here it's like this,
this,
this visions book.
Alex.
Cool.
You're seeing that stuff before.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It makes sure you have,
but uh,
he's um,
creating that like the cover of this uh,
um,
visions book.
He's creating something that's,
that's beautiful.
That cover.
Yeah.
He's creating something
really similar to this,
like this style of art.
Like this,
the style thing as a building,
he's going to have a religious
building called the end theone.
That's like this nondenominational
spiritual sort of
building that he's putting
together and it's going to,
how's it inside this building that's
created essentially out of psychedelic art
and he did a Kickstarter and
offered a lot of really cool shit,
including painting people's personal
or drawing people's personal pictures,
drawing,
drawing of an Alex Gray version
of them and a lot of cool shit.
I need to do a Kickstarter to get a
condo somewhere nice and like Malibu or
something.
I'll make it spiritual if you want me to.
We can all smoke weed if you want.
Well,
thousand bucks,
you get to crash on the couch once.
That's all right.
That's not how Kickstarter works on.
They have to get something out of it too.
Well,
I'll film it and you guys can all download
me and my new condo in Malibu Sucking
Dick.
Why did you say suck it today,
Brian there.
Just think about what you're saying
and then count to three and then stay.
Stay with the thought and he goes,
this worth saying,
I mean,
it's like you can't,
um,
you can't just have a Kickstarter
to get yourself a condos on.
No,
you can't.
Well,
you can do is you could say,
Hey,
I'm making a documentary about me getting
a super sick condo in Malibu and I
need 300 and no.
Well,
$200,000.
To tell you what Brian,
nobody would see that comment that is
basically bulletproof and no one would
ever call scam.
They would say,
hey,
you're just doing this so that you could
get this super dope condo or buddy.
Uh,
John,
uh,
has a nice Kickstarter.
Schwab,
what is his,
uh,
Les Schwab,
Schwab.
I,
it's too,
uh,
for him to become super rich.
That's the whole Kickstarter.
John was Wa you may recognize me
from my popular youtube videos,
televisions,
the league,
or simply as someone you admire an
envy because I'm awesome and famous.
My fans come up to me all
the time and asked me,
John,
what aren't you going to make a movie?
My answer is always the same.
It's bodyguard
beat the shit out of this gross poor
person who's not addressing me as surly
Schwab.
A second most common
question I get from my fans.
Stop right there.
If I was his friend,
I'd say edit that.
What was that part I didn't get with
that part was parts called not funny.
They just swing,
didn't work.
He's a funny guy.
You know we all fucking
throw turns up there.
Actually we was trying to do,
didn't work.
Oh man,
you were great.
The last time I saw you
at the laugh factory.
It was like six months ago.
Oh thanks man.
Thank you.
Dig Bit about that.
The horse fuck video.
Ah Damn.
It was,
it was like a 10 minute bit.
It was straight.
I was just there and
it's called Enim cloth.
Oh really?
I was just there.
Yeah,
and they're all very embarrassed about it.
It's really interesting.
I like brass plaques up marking.
Well it's a real rural area.
It's at the base of a mountain.
I think it's a Mount Rainier.
It's to the,
it's one of those mountain communities
and they were really bummed out that
their,
their town is known for that now.
Like you ask him about it.
They were,
there's a few like really nice.
There's a place called Charlie's shout
out to Charlie's the best fucking
pancakes you'll ever eat in your life,
man.
And eat claw.
Pretty fucking dynamite.
It's like a real like home cooking place.
We were up there looking for bigfoot
for this new show I'm doing
isn't the definition of looking.
There has to be something to actually see.
Brian is,
you're not the expert of
everything doesn't exist.
You're not looking.
Oh you say it doesn't exist,
but how do you know that's
like looking for goats.
You can't really look for
wine and it doesn't exist,
which you can,
you can go look for ghosts.
It doesn't mean you're
going to find it goes.
But if there are ghosts
occasionally and you're not looking,
you're never going to find them.
And if you're living your whole life,
never seen a ghost do you?
Like there's no fucking goes.
And then one day you see a ghost,
you shit yourself and you
don't have a picture of it.
You can never explain it.
And you try to tell people and they like,
yeah,
you saw it ghost because no one's going
to ever believe anything that they
haven't seen themselves.
Unless you could show me a picture
of it unless you can show me.
I don't even believe in quantum theory.
You know why?
Cause he can't show it to me.
I don't know what you're doing.
I show all,
see all those lines and squiggles.
I believe you're correct.
I would never doubt,
but I don't,
I have no idea if that's real.
I have no idea if that's real,
but big foot.
I think he's real.
You know,
you do not think he's real.
Tom Rounds the tell you what man.
Hey man,
if anything's real,
you're entitled.
That the only thing is real.
I think Eddie Murphy,
he's a better actor.
Denzel Washington
or you be serious.
You're just being silly.
I think we all have,
we're all entitled to our opinions.
Seriously being silly because any,
if we can act as dicta up,
he just doesn't do it very often.
I think he acted it already.
I bet he did his bed at best acting when
the cops asked him why that training
was in his car.
It was a little character.
Do the research.
I was taking him home officer,
that is ain't homeless.
Tranny explained yourself,
but I guarantee you that,
I mean,
look at how good he was and um,
uh,
the nick naulty 48 hours,
it's fucking great in that movie.
Great.
As an actor as well,
like not just great as a bad
guy and you know what else,
what was he like four
different characters.
That's something that,
and I'm not endorsing
this movie in any way,
shape or form,
but that Ben Stiller movie about,
uh,
the robbery,
the fucking there was on the top floor,
the penthouse something.
It was like,
what the hell was that called?
The heist heist heist.
Not a bad movie really was,
it got,
took a lot of shit.
It was pretty fun.
The premise is ridiculous,
but Eddie Murphy's a
bad ass fucking actor.
Like,
you forget how subtly is like,
how he could pull shit off though.
You know,
it's really sad that all that trainee
shit went down because when that trainee
shit went down,
Eddie Murphy stopped doing stand up,
you know,
he did raw and then,
he kinda like just went to movies and
maybe he would have went back 10 years
after raw and then the
trainee thing was it?
Yeah,
it was a than my timeline's wrong,
but I just feel like maybe he
would've gone back to it if it wasn't.
I wish she would've.
That's why I was excited when he was
going to host the Oscars that like,
just give us a hint of it,
Eddie,
just a couple of minutes.
This is the truth.
When Raul came out and I was,
uh,
I don't know how old I was,
I guess I was probably 18
or something like that.
I don't remember.
Somewhere around that.
Somewhere around the teenage years.
And I remember seeing raw on TV and we,
me and my friends were fucking crying.
We're crying and it doesn't totally hold
up today because a lot of the premises
have been like beaten down since then.
A lot.
I remember that was an
event when it came out,
it was in the theaters,
but you coming off a delirious,
delirious was so strong.
Oh,
you know what?
Every moment and then it was like he
had gotten money and then he's telling
stories about bodyguards and bill
Cosby actually meant delirium.
Delirious said that because yeah,
I told this was the TV one.
That was the HBO where he's in the back,
the movie and he's got the blue suit.
No,
I definitely met you and your
friends were really laughable.
Rod Rod was not that good.
That's it.
No,
that was like,
it was like when rap
guys get too much money,
when they rap guys come out,
they're great.
The first three albums or from the street,
they got the message
and then like the third,
fourth album,
dude,
who's going to clean my pool is late.
You know,
there's some of that money that takes
the sting out of a lot of people and then
awesome.
Then he had gotten a
few live changes round.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know the life you live as a comedian,
there's gotta be some folly in it,
you know,
and when everyone's just lining up to
suck your Dick and pay you in diamonds,
this is not a lot of the following.
Did you see that,
that Eddie Murphy thing?
Well it was on comedy central.
They,
um,
they did some like,
you know,
honor him evening and who
was it told this great story?
Um,
oh my God,
I forgot it.
It's a,
but I guess it was
Arsenio Hall or something.
And some woman comes over there at like
some black club and some white woman
comes over to Eddie Murphy goes,
Eddie,
I love you.
I've never,
I never kissed a,
uh,
a black man before.
Can I kiss you?
And he goes,
no.
He goes,
you don't start at the top.
You got to start with one of these poor.
And that's fine.
You can't start at the top.
Pay Delirious.
You know,
before delirious,
he had a CD.
I don't even have a CD.
I think it was like a set,
but he had a cassette
that was really good.
I think maybe even better than delirious
cause it was really like low pressure.
Give delirious has a gift.
I got,
I get a little nephew man and he likes
comedy and then like the lyrics a little
like teenage kids and stuff,
they want to like,
uh,
you know,
they asked me,
who should I,
who should I study?
Here's delirious.
Let's start start here.
If you're like a teenager and you're
not really into radical shit yet,
you just send the solid funny,
it's too bad that he stopped.
You know,
it's interesting,
you know,
there was also,
it's just a,
I'm sure when you're probably the number
one comedy movie star in the world,
like it's probably really hard to get
up a desire to go write and create new
jokes and they're probably just constantly
shoving movies down his face back
then.
You know,
he went in after 48 hours
and I mean he was gigantic,
gigantic.
He was,
I liked the party,
Yada.
No,
it's my girl wants to
had a hit song and dance song.
It was a hit song about his
girl who to party all the time.
That is a drag man.
If you're dating a girl and she just
wants to go out all the time and dance and
party.
I don't like the friends I've met friends
break up of girls cause they just want
a party all the time to like listen,
okay you're,
you're escaping something here.
We can't do coke seven nights in a row.
All right.
Keep needed.
He needed to take a nap
and you need to get a help.
Wanted,
look,
pick up that.
Finding an occupation.
You can't just be out there partying
or you can forget it if you got an act,
you know,
travel the country Tom road style.
Just go gangster.
Tell it road the road.
Glad you clarified that.
You're like,
you can't party all the time.
I'm like oh parties all the time.
Do you ever think that a,
you're going to settle down in the city?
Yeah.
I'm considering a few places
where you consider him a,
I'd like to move back to
San Francisco and just a,
you know,
just,
I mean,
just creating jokes.
That's the,
uh,
you know,
that's the main mission.
Yeah.
I liked it.
The,
you know,
the tech industry is based
out of there and I think,
you know,
uh,
things are moving.
I think that the future,
I mean like you can be your own
movie mogul studio now and uh,
I,
you know,
I don't know.
I think,
um,
you know,
it's a lot of entertainment.
Yeah,
no,
there certainly is.
I think that's too,
it's a great place to do stand up.
It's also a lot of smart people there.
It's a good audience.
When I come to La,
I like staying in Nice hotels,
you know,
some of that living here and paying rent.
I Dunno.
Maybe I haven't lived in
the right neighborhood.
Can I crash at your place
for a couple of months?
Sorry,
I'll sweep the helicopter
pad every once in a while.
You won't get along with the family.
I'm like,
this guy is just,
he's going to draw you to the dark side.
Don't worry.
My will is strong.
I'm kidding.
I uh,
I don't know.
And then also,
you know,
and then New Orleans is a
place that I would consider,
that's a wild sound.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a free town there.
The,
that's like almost like you should
have a passport to go to New Orleans.
It seems like some sort of Caribbean
island you just drop off into connected to
the rest of the country.
And,
and then again,
uh,
I,
I wouldn't mind moving back to,
to Amsterdam or Europe maybe,
you know,
get a place.
And Tim,
what about for your stand up?
What do you think would be the best place?
Do you like to have a
home club to work out of?
No,
but I,
you know,
I love the stand hope model.
You know,
he works his ass off for like two or
three months and then you'll take a month
off,
you know,
go home to take several
months off at times.
And I liked that.
I liked that he does that where I'm,
I'll only take a week or two off,
you know.
Uh,
I liked that notion,
Stan hope was doing it the perfect way.
Yeah.
He's so,
I mean it's so,
so with that in mind,
you could live anywhere,
you know,
you,
why not have a place in Greece or
in south of France or you know,
more travel time.
That's,
that's the pain of the deck.
And some people like to have a club
that's close that they can fuck around and
practice that.
Like when I lived in Boulder,
I was doing the comedy in Denver.
It's only like an hour and a half
from where I live.
It's pretty easy.
Drive down there,
boom,
do a set,
get right back to the wilderness,
you know,
it's like that way.
Get sort of the best of both
worlds type situation going on.
You know,
I think that a,
a home clubs.
Nice.
It's nice to have a spot.
So like we're standing up is on Bisbee.
There's no fucking club.
So that crazy asshole.
Just do a show in his back yard,
set up some speakers,
plug the Mike and
he did a show in Vegas
and some dude's backyard.
There was a guy in Vegas,
some kid who was hiring comedians to do
shows in his yard and have his friends
come over and uh,
it was supposed to be a great gig.
San Jose,
he say about it,
right?
Said it was awesome.
We got it.
Got It.
Got shut down by like city
ordinances or something.
Yeah,
he didn't have the proper permit.
That's a bummer.
What the fuck is that?
When would the proper permits are?
Well then you could shut
down lemonade stands,
you know,
so you don't,
and you don't have a permit.
Right.
But you don't want anybody throwing
like crazy late night parties in the
backyard next to you.
That would suck.
Like what if they were
playing bad rap music?
Like you're cool with it if it's stand up.
And it's funny,
like it's Stan Hope.
Do I stand out or whatever.
Some terrible,
whoo,
whoo hoo.
Yeah.
Did you see?
He tried to get some fucking
sleep and you're like,
God damn it,
this is death.
Maybe that's how they
feel about Stan hope.
Talking about aids.
When I,
uh,
when I turned 16,
my parents made the tactical error of
going out of town that weekend and I threw
one of the biggest parties Oviedo high
school had ever seen and there were just
cars parked all down the block and
just massive party and people just,
you know,
drinking on,
I,
I was uh,
talking to like three of the
hottest girls in my school,
in our living room and
this guy vomits on the,
on our living room,
carpet.
You know what I mean?
What am I do?
I'm going to get down
on my hands and knees,
you know,
in the middle of this party or that,
these girls that I,
I care about,
uh,
you know,
watch me cleaned some vomit.
Ha.
So what'd you do?
He sprinkled some dog food on
it and let the dog in that?
No.
Did you really?
Oh,
you fucking foul human being.
Why would you want to
dog me drinking diet?
It was a the cleanest carpet area
that dog haunted you with dog farts.
Poor dog.
Come on ripping horrible farts.
Bio farts.
Worst here.
Your dog's Fart.
When you look over it and be like,
come on man,
for real.
Hey,
that's when the dog is
comfortable with you.
They're always comfortable with your man.
They never hold in farts.
I was just something about dogs.
They never figured it out.
You yell at them when they farm.
They never put two and two together like
what the fuck are you yelling at him,
man,
I'm just here doing my steak.
I'm just being mad.
I didn't even move
fucking stinky bitch.
You ever have a dog
wake you up with a fart?
My dogs used to Fart so bad.
I'd be in bed.
I'm black.
Oh God.
What the fuck?
It was like I was eating shit in bed.
No,
especially if you feed them wet food.
That's the key.
Dogs love that wet food.
But that wet food would just just
all gels together and stomach and the
fermentation process and
then when it comes out,
just,
Oh,
you're just,
you feel it.
You feel it.
Before you even smell it.
Oh my God,
we got this subject.
What?
Doug Fir forest,
if you like dogs,
you got to deal with that.
It's a weird thing that we
have certain animals that we,
we,
we cherish and certain
animals that we just,
you know,
we slaughter on a regular basis
and they're clearly defined.
And when we step outside of those lines,
people get really upset.
I was watching this
thing on TV where they,
uh,
it was in the,
one of the British papers,
they were showing these this,
the latest trend is can the lion hunts.
Oh,
I just saw that on the Guardian.
The Guardian.
That's what it was.
Yeah.
I love the Guardian.
It's really crazy.
If you haven't seen it,
the raise these ends discuss,
did you see that?
It was on today's in today's
go guardian on their website,
us.
And it was this beautiful lion,
just massive line.
And the guy standing there,
we're like,
oh,
this is right Baltic underneath it.
Yeah.
Well what's really crazy is this,
is this not even a wild lion
that's inside of a fence.
These are hand raised lions.
So what they do is they
take them from their mother,
like right away,
all they see is people,
they see lion cubs and people and the
people provide them food and the people
pet them.
So that's how you train these
lines to be more docile.
So that's how when people were
wandering around shooting these lines,
these lines aren't stalking them and
killing them because these lions associate
people with being like their parents.
So this is like one of the weirdest,
strangest sort of canned hunts ever
because it's like shooting big dogs.
It's really similar shit.
What's the sport in that?
If you see how these lions are
with the people that are in this,
uh,
this park,
before they send them to this park,
there's another company that's a farm
that grows these lions and they take them
away from their mom and then they feed
them with bottles and they're cuddling
with him and shit.
And then when they get full grown,
then they let him loose in this park
and it's just this big giant fenced in
place.
And the lions are walking around and
then they let loose the white people.
And then the white people come in with
these guns and they set up and there's
like four or five guys,
Shit went the lions because the lion
makes it charge when you shoot them,
if you heard them,
they'll fucking charge at you.
They know what happened.
And so you got to like have like four
or five dudes at the same time shooting.
So watch this,
like the lines just
sitting there chilling.
Oh yeah they do.
I'll look.
So he shot at him and missed the
line of what the fuck's going on.
The line doesn't recognize
it as a threat at all.
And then now he hit him.
Now the lions running at them and then
they dropped the camera cause they the
line hit with a bullet.
Okay,
it's dying but it's running at them.
So they just started firing at
it as it's running fat white men.
Well this is so crazy because this is Gus.
This is not even something
that you would eat for food.
And they're pretending that
this is the dangerous game.
They pretending that this is the,
they're the great white hunter and
they're out there taking down a lie in and
then they have it in their home.
Look,
this is a lion I shot
while I was in Africa,
but really they've done,
they've taken the balls
out of the lion hunt.
Dang.
Right.
See Look,
there's four guys with rifles.
Yeah,
I remember I went to,
I was in Savia Spain and uh,
I went to the bull fights.
I had seen it once in,
in Mexico and it was
one dude versus a bowl,
you know,
uh,
I had read Hemingway's
death in the afternoon,
you know,
manly.
It was like the minor
leagues of bull fighting.
There was four guys against one bull.
One guy goes out there with the Red Cape
and then another dude sneaks up behind
it with the prongs and sticks it in it.
And I got upset.
It was like the most cowardly chicken
shit stuff I'd ever seen in my life.
And that's what that
lion thing reminds me.
I would like really for guys with rifles
isn't those things.
They Jab in the bowl,
aren't they poisoned as well?
Hm.
I Dunno.
I didn't think so.
I thought,
oh they poison Brian.
You know what time those things that
jab and a bowl during a bull fighting it
aren't.
They may have poison in them.
No,
I don't know.
I'm touring.
I think they do,
but either way they're stabbing.
I'm,
you know,
fucking him up.
He's hurt bad.
Yeah.
It's that,
that line thing
disturbing.
It's really disturbing,
which just shows how weak people are.
It's just such a weird thing to want to
show you that everything is for sale.
You can have any experience you want.
If you're really flush.
They've appealed to the weakest of,
of people.
You know,
the people that would want to go there
just to shoot something and say they shot
it in.
So you're shooting a pet.
I mean essentially that's a pet
that's been let loose and this,
the fact that they're trying to look at
this little hot dog is licking a lion,
you know?
Oh,
that's adorable.
That's adorable.
You know,
like,
like that line clearly
is not a fucking day.
I mean if you went,
if you went to his case will probably
fuck your world up if you want it.
And you know,
the man lion,
uh,
it's pretty lazy.
It's just lie around
and fuck all the time.
The woman lion does all the hunting,
right?
Yeah.
If he's well fed,
the male lion is there to defend,
to make sure that he protects the,
uh,
the females and the cubs against other
males that will come in and try to rough
everybody up and eat all the babies.
That's a,
when a new male comes in the big mail,
it has to be able to keep that mail
out because if that mail gets in,
it's very likely he's
going to kill all the cubs.
If they're not his,
he'll just dominate,
takeover,
start fucking all these checks
again and kill their babies.
So that's what the male is supposed to do.
Wait,
I'm supposed to just take care of
everything and fight off hyenas.
There you got lions.
Just sad.
It's edutainment.
It's sad that people
would want to do that.
They would actually want to go and shoot
some something that's basically a pat
and in this fenced in area,
you know,
we've,
we've talked about a Ted Nugent on the
show before Ted Nugent has a show called
the spirit of the wild.
It's kind of fascinating.
Um,
and he has a,
these ranches,
two of them,
one up in Minnesota and one in Texas
with his offense din ranch with all these
deer running around on it.
And he sits up in a tree and he puts
food out and the deer walk up to the food
and it sticks.
And with a bow and Arrow,
his bow.
Yeah,
but he eats all the meat.
I mean,
that's all he eats.
And he enjoys doing it and you know,
it's all his property,
Jeremy,
it makes you very flatulent.
So He's a [inaudible].
He said,
what'd you hear that I
haven't you ever had venison?
Yeah.
Half Lights.
The buddle hold up.
Hmm.
Maybe that's a personal thing.
I reveal too much about what
makes me flatulence milk.
No ice cream,
ice cream and have horrible farts.
Did,
uh,
what was it politically incorrect when
it was on comedy central years ago?
Yeah.
When Bill Maher was first,
you know,
this first version of
his show with Ted Nugent.
So nobody got in an edge,
a word,
edgewise,
because he's just,
he just dominated the ball.
Yeah.
And afterwards we're in the green room
and he comes up to me and he puts his arm
around me.
It's time,
uh,
I like you man.
And,
uh,
I want you to cause it
to have my magazine.
And he had,
he's got the magazine in his left hand.
He's got his right arm
around me and it's called,
it's,
uh,
Ted Nugent's bowhunting magazine.
He goes,
no time.
This magazine is more than about bow hunt.
This is about you and who you are as a
man and getting in touch with your inner
being.
I read the fucking magazines
cover to cover.
It was about bowling.
It had nothing to do with me.
Well,
let's see him.
That's what bowhunting is about.
Bow Hunting is about some spiritual quest,
you know,
to tap into the essence of the wall,
the wilderness.
Right.
He does it with an Arrow.
That's Kinda,
that's old school.
Well it is.
He's a,
I mean,
he's really good at what does that song,
oh,
that's right.
Why must we eat the animals?
But that's right.
This is a real video,
by the way.
This is a white guy and
this is a Vegan reggae song.
Oh Wow.
And if this doesn't make you both
laugh and want to get violent.
Yes.
The beans up this way.
The animals have language amenities
that you got to see their videos to
is off for cultivation or human bias.
Look at how fucking this is.
Why must we eat the animals?
When I was in this,
when I was in New Zealand,
there was a billboard for something.
I don't know if it was a
restaurant or something,
but it's at a,
if it didn't have a mother,
it doesn't go on our grill.
They won't even cook beans.
They won't even grill Zucchini.
Get the fuck Outta here
with this guy's hilarious.
And he's showing like things in this
video that people don't eat like big
whales.
What's your rough Japanese people do hunt
the whales and he's like the cow here.
You know,
here's the real problem
with this philosophy.
If you really did that,
do you know how many people would
get sick from poor nutrition?
First of all,
they already are,
right?
So that's a bad argument.
But the real issue is what are you
going to do with all these animals now?
Cause if you're not killing them,
you better introduce some predators into
the food chain because otherwise you're
going to have deer everywhere.
You weren't gonna be able to drive.
You're not going to,
your cows are going to be all over it.
You're gonna keep him from fucking,
you're going to castrate them.
You gonna what are you going to do?
How are you gonna?
How are you going to neuter them?
How you get to manage the population?
Are you going to kill a few?
What do you do then?
And no need to meet?
That seems pretty ridiculous when people
are starving in the world and your
ships and shipping and boxes of
fresh vegetables that are rotting.
My favorite sandwiches,
the BLT,
it's great.
Sam,
how are you going to,
how are you going to in sandwich?
You can take away bacon
dude.
I been eating the fuck out of Bacon.
Lightly big is good for you.
I went back to Baygon.
Fuck yeah you did.
I said I had like,
my father was a baker and his stories,
I like started getting
Turkey Bacon and I was like,
oh,
this tastes good enough man.
Fuck that.
Good fat bacon like re
like freshly sliced bacon.
Not like the,
the Oscar Meyer packs that
you can buy your hard core.
Your uh,
yeah.
You're the boars head at the Deli.
You get that Bacon.
Do you ever get the bacon
they have at the um,
at whole foods?
Yes.
Oh yeah.
You cannot bacon.
You gotta go Rob Wolf style though.
Dude.
You get a cook it slow.
You got to get a big frying
pan and cook it slow.
He doesn't unlike some electrical Jamey,
but he cooks his bacon
for like three hours.
Yeah.
But when you do it that way,
like if you ever go to like a four seasons
and you eat at the buffet and he get
that Bacon,
you're like,
hell no.
Fuck are they doing this?
Cause my bacon is always fucked up.
Twisted black.
They're baking is like consistent and
Perri a rich brown and it's so perfect.
It's cause they're slow
cook in that batch,
cooking that pitch.
Let me go get some bacon right now.
It's podcast is over.
Tom Rhodes,
you're a bad motherfucker.
Glad we're friends.
I like to buy specs,
respect and please let's
do this more often.
It's,
yeah,
I totally,
I love your show man.
And then,
then you know,
it's uh,
you coming on again.
All right,
you fuck,
I love you daddy.
Love you too,
man.
All right.
Thank you everybody for
tuning into the podcast.
We appreciate the shit out of you.
Thanks to audible.com for sponsoring
the podcast to audible.com
forward slash Joe and get yourself free.
30 days of service and
one free audio book,
the Premiere Audio
Resource on the Internet.
I love audible.com.
They're a fucking fantastic company.
Go,
go check them out.
We're also brought to you by hover.
If you uh,
go to hover.com forward slash Rogen,
you will save 10% off any of your domain
name registrations were also brought to
you by [inaudible] dot com.
That's O,
n n I t.
Use the code name,
Rogan save 10% off any
and all supplements.
We are gone until a Thursday night and
Thursday night I'm going to be doing a
special,
uh,
after I get off of work,
the guy with Kelly Start and Kelly is a,
uh,
a,
he's growing to be very popular
on the Internet with uh,
some really excellent ideas
about maintaining your body,
taking care of injuries and shit.
So we're going to talk to them about,
about that,
the Schumann then that to me we can to
get down and dirty about muscles and
tendons and ligaments and shit and discs.
Um,
and then uh,
Monday we'll be back with
Bobcat Goldthwait and uh,
we got some other cool,
cool guests next week.
All right,
you fucks.
We love the shit out of Ya.
Friday.
Yeah.
Friday ice house.
Friday.
Icehouse Tom Rhodes,
Joey Diaz,
um,
me.
Brian Red Ban.
Um,
and maybe leaving your Brian calendar
drive down after does it show in
Calabasas.
Okay.
We love you.
All right.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you.
Okay.